and we are live ready for this i'm not a gm speed
chess championship match between gotham chess levy
rosman and i am rosen eric rosen i'm on it's
gonna be a heavyweight battle two of the most
popular streamers on the web who's gonna take this
one that's a great question robert and when we're
all looking for the answer for i saw the chat poll
right before you and i went live here and it was
neck and neck i think 45 to 43 with the remaining
going there cat jam or some guy i've never heard
of but it is going to be a super close one and
i love that we're uh got this prime time slot
robert really feels you mentioned heavyweight
matchup i think that uh you know this is going
to be one of the most exciting matches in the
entire competition it certainly will be and
the everyone in the audience is familiar with
the players let's remind them of the format
so to get used to what we'll see as the night goes
on it is a single elimination knockout brackets
the loser of this match well you're not continuing
in this tournament it is 75 minutes of five minute
plus one second increment blitz followed by 45
minutes of the three plus one and finally we get
to 25 minutes of bullet and the winner moves on
and of course we have the prize fund it is 300 and
more importantly advancing the semifinals and then
the rest 300 is split by win percentage and i'm on
as we take a look at the bracket how we got here
where we're going it is the bottom left-hand side
of the bracket we have levy rosman as the four
seed eric rosen as the five seed and this is just
the matchup everyone's been waiting for yeah this
is uh as you can see from the bracket there this
is basically the final spot that we have to fill
um in the the semi-finals leading into the finals
so this is going to determine everything that
you know the winner is going to move on to play
against greg shahade which is he's the number one
seed in the whole thing so right after this match
no matter who wins you're guaranteed another big
matchup as the winner is going to take on craig
that's for sure the case and it's almost nine on
the east coast everyone here in the audience is
feeling fine i see the chat going crazy because
they're excited about gotham chess versus i am
rosen and well we can see the players right now
we can bring them on screen for you they've got
their hoodies on they're you know they're ready
for this match and i wonder if they're nervous
to you know settle score here and determine which
of these two is going through to the semi-finals
yeah it's it's really really tough to call um
this matchup i think on paper the players are so
similarly rated and if i had to pick someone who
uh i guess maybe would be more nervous i feel like
i might say levy and that's just based on his
post-game interview that he gave in the last
match where he was like you know listen i have
to admit i was a little nervous and uh rosen
always seems so cool and and so calm but who
knows you know what's hiding behind the facade
that does appear to be the case most of the
time and we know what it's like commentating
the pressures off we want to bring entertainment
and education to the masses but you don't feel
that same pressure like when you are playing and
for levy who during the day has been covering the
champions chess tour and of course providing
excellent content going up on youtube daily
now he has to pick up the pieces himself and
take on a very strong opponent eric rosen
yeah and you've uh talked to so many different
players over the course of this i'm not a gm
competition so many other content creators
are actually commentators themselves so
you know with all work that levy's been doing
commentating you make a good point you know
kenny transitioned back to a very very uh intense
matchup that he's gonna have to deal with uh eric
rosen i mean they're so evenly matched in blitz
and bullet um i i think that uh on paper this
might be the closest matchup rating wise yeah it
is very close probably about 50 points separate
them but it's at the different time controls
because there is that one second increment
you can't flag your opponents as easily and
let's say you're used to playing hyper bullet
rather than one minute bullet it just affects
the same rating but it's a different game so
it's going to be an interesting battle and we're
just a minute away now the chat is really stoked
and they're picking their sides that's clear yes
they are i saw a gifted sub bomb from chesapeake
in the chat there to energize the people and maybe
give them a few extra emails to spam and i mean
the the chat right now is energized robert as i
mentioned i'm just hyped for this prime time slot
we don't get to commentate too many of these
matches in the evening and it just it just always
makes things feel more prime time it for sure does
and the players they're stretching they're getting
yeah their bodies ready to sit in these chairs
and compete in intense blitz chests for the next
few hours and you know eric i feel like it's
hard to tell if he's winning or losing just by
body language because he has that same mannerisms
regardless and for levy i think it's important him
to start on a good note because against canty it
didn't feel like he found his footing until the
latter part of the three-minute portion canty
was really keeping with him game by game there
and then finally lead was able to break free and
you could sense that confidence and levy's been
working really hard i saw he played alexander
castaneuk that's chess queen in a match so he's
taking this seriously he's getting his practice
reps in and eric rosen also taken seriously he
said hey when i'm playing these events i take
a bit of a break from streaming to focus on
my studying and i love that i think that's
how the players should treat these events um
i think what i've noticed from this edition of the
i am not a gm tournament is that most players have
uh said that that is the case you know they have
taken time off from what they're usually doing and
put a lot of effort into their matches you know
some people even said well you know i'm preparing
for these matches more than my you know my own uh
commentary or my own over the board games whatever
it is so i i just like to see that from the
players they are fully committed to these matches
and um i think that levy is now in a position
where he knows that eric rosen is you know a very
tough even match for him and uh you know what
they say you often play up to the standards of
your opponent so maybe he felt as the favorite in
the last match that you know he he wasn't supposed
to play maybe his best chess and he might win
anyway well now he's gonna have to play his best
chess and we do have liftoff we see that levy's
going for this g3 he's going to fee and kettle the
bishop take the long diagonal this has the feel of
a catalan the difference being that white hasn't
committed this pawn to d4 yet and i generally like
this position stylistically for white you get a
bit of a plus just with your piece quality but the
problem can be if you don't recapture that c4 pawn
that can be a problem especially in a blitz game
yeah and there's a lot of uh you know theory and
preparation that goes into some variations where
you try to keep this pawn you know with the b5 and
a6 or rook b8 um you know and for white often you
might see a queen a4 move early on just to make
sure that you get this pawn back and you don't
have to deal with positions where uh you're sort
of getting concerned well hang on am i getting
that pawn back at all and look at this queen a4
knight d7 breaking the pin on the knight and c6
and after queen takes over knight b6 hitting the
queen bringing both knights over to the queen side
and then finally black can finish development but
let me ask you what if you play move okay you want
queen c2 i was thinking of queen c3 how do you
get that dark squish square bishop out but instead
the queen drops to c2 which is its natural habitat
yeah i was um even yeah okay so i was wondering
about the move e5 and the reason being that if
black is gonna you know take the time to cycle his
knight away from what most of us would consider a
very natural square f6 there has to be something
that he's planning if he's just going bishop e7
and castling i'm wondering why you put the
knight there and it looks like with the move
e5 bishop e7 uh we're almost transposing back to
you know a different line of theory where um in
the english black plays d5 and captures and then
puts the knight on b6 so i don't know what the
move count is here robert but maybe we're
back in some sort of theory in english
yeah and it's a reverse sicilian right where
white is missing the c pawn and this would be
black and sicilian and then you see the position
arise like this and eric plays a5 he's taking
up space in the queen side he's stopping b4
and levy plays the thematic bishop e3 that
may look weird to some putting your bishop in
front of the pawn but it's attacking the knight
on b6 excuse me and also the bishop can plant
himself on c5 if you want to start taking over
squares on the c file yeah that's a great point
and if people are wondering you've already
mentioned that as sort of a reverse sicilian
just think about the dragon setup and it's
actually really common for black to play bishop
e6 in that setup it's the exact same thing here
so in some cases this bishop can even be taken
and white would say you know f takes e3 sure i
get the open file and i control the d4 square
probably what eric's going to be looking to do
at some point you know rookie 8 and knight d4
there's going to be a moment where there's a
choice from uh um eric rosen here do i play knight
d4 uh and he's gotta time that correctly that's
right h4 plane and f6 the immediate response and
f6 kind of says to h4 well you're not getting that
g5 square for your piece now my knight on c6 is
free to move because e5 is well defended and i
would consider a4 especially after rook d1 give me
that b3 square if i get my bishop to b3 i skewer
your queen and then your rook so now that the rook
is on d1 i'm even more tempted to play that move
yeah a4 is uh really natural in these positions
anyway it looks like after a4 bishop takes b6 you
can even throw in that bishop d3 move intermezzo
to make sure that you don't drop the a4 upon
that's right because that would be a big pawn to
drop just push it there and then lose it but that
intermezzo could play into black's hands although
there are positions where you can just sacrifice
an exchange and claim that you get a bishop and a
pawn for your troubles or knight and upon in this
case and that might be worth it for the rook yeah
and it looks like d4 is the consideration here so
roseanne i mean if not a4 which maybe tactically
deals with d4 i was going to say he needs some
solution here because after playing the move f6 d4
for white is usually the central break that causes
some problems and knight ends up on d4 all of a
sudden it's hitting the bishop on e6 the knight on
c6 the bishop on g2 opens up on that long diagonal
and the rook on d1 opens up against the queen and
we're seeing a major drawback of the pawn being
on h4 rather than on h2 because in the sicilian if
you think about from the perspective of a sicilian
for the black pieces you could sometimes allow
this knight to capture the bishop on e3 but levy
was kind of forced to react because allowing that
capture now would leave the g3 pawn vulnerable so
that's why he took first but now black played e4
the knight moves away and then f5 and that pawn
on e4 is such a thorn in the bishop on g2 side
yeah completely agree this is what you don't want
usually as white so i'm getting the feeling that
this is uh trending in a good direction for
rosen after knight d2 f5 as you mentioned and
again if that pawn was on h2 you might consider
something like f3 to break the position down but
that pawn up to h4 is looking like a move that
levy's gonna want back and look at that eric just
pre-moves f5 and you're right that that pawn would
love to go back to h2 you feel safer for your king
now their idea is to sacrifice on h4 and push
your pawn to f4 you have to keep an eye on that
it looks very dangerous already for levy and he
doesn't have a concrete plan that's the issue
when you get into a position with that bishop
on d5 it really stops all of white's play white
would actually love to throw that d4 pawn off the
board and give me the open file give me space for
my pieces but that bishop 1d5 blockades the whole
center yeah and bishop f6 just watching that e5
uh square where the knight might want to jump in
i think if levy can get maybe bishop f4 and e3
in with rook ac1 you know that's sort of
the long-term setup he might want to go for
controlling the e5 square and uh you know his
his rooks are certainly much better placed
than than eric's rooks at the moment that's true
and i might be probably like to here and play a4
just say hey please go 95 you know move that
knight because i want to get my bishop to b3
and eric plays queen eight this makes sense
the pawn's on h4 it's you can go for a king
side attack with queen h5 or something like that
or just put your queen on a square like e e6 or f7
and go for bishop to p3 if that knight ever moves
out the way you can get that skewer at long last
yeah queen e6 queen f7 i like e6 because f7 feels
like it's going to be hit at some point with a
knight like 95 so queen e6 looks like a great
square for that a4 we've mentioned a few times
definitely a big consideration and levy is
i'm pretty sure looking at the move 95 it was
probably playable in that last position um knight
e5 but you know eric doesn't have to take that
that's right and here queen e6 you can still try
for 95 but now i'm going to take it because i have
my bishop and my queen protecting that e5 square i
will win a pawn and my bishop 155 can be protected
by the pawn coming to c6 so bishop f4 played and
all right i just see the eval bar drop which means
knight takes d4 followed by c5 is probably just a
knockout yep yep that looks uh that looks strong
there however it's something that you would
think twice about you know in a game because
it looks like there might be some maybe rook
moves to consider some rook takes d5 rook takes
e4 there's just a few extra things to calculate
but if you look at the clock i think eric does
have the time to maybe notice that i see now why
levy played the move queen c3 he wanted that setup
that i've been talking about so much bishop f4 and
e3 but eric has to strike right now otherwise he's
going to achieve that and he does go rook f7 so
knight takes d4 it's hard to play that because
it looks like there are some variations where
white gets a bunch of pieces for that queen
and it's not so clear to figure out who's on
top so he goes rook f7 now that knight can
come to e3 and that's what levy does bishop b3
no longer the same threat there could be some d5
ideas and all complications in that position and
aristotle think again before playing bishop to b3
it might be a good move but d5 is what would make
me nervous about it absolutely no i usually you do
not want that bishop to leave and then d5 and look
at all the pieces it's like taking on e6 takes on
f7 with check every piece in eric's position is
sort of on the wrong square for that d5 push and
he plays it so if d5 you know what's funny he can
just go bishop back and take on d5 i was thinking
oh do i take the queen and then you take my queen
on e6 but he can just take the pawn right back
on d5 and then say hey your queen's still under
attack yeah now it's your turn again yeah it's uh
it's easy to overlook that kind of stuff so eric
props him for playing bishop to b3 but also levy
has worked his way and created some threats
because even if you don't have d5 right now
you can line that up in the near future absolutely
i mean rook d2 is definitely playable knight c2
um knight c2 looks playable as well you're gonna
get some e3 and one thing to be careful of is this
light squared bishop as soon as it comes alive in
the position be careful like bishop f1 to c4 in
the future or bishop h3 targeting f5 that's right
and a4 was a very important move speaking of light
square bishops that bishop on b3 was hanging
if the queen got distracted so knight takes f5
was a distraction tactic to win the bishop on b3
for that knight but that's why a4 is so strong it
cements that bishop in place also you could think
about playing knight a5 at some point or even rook
a5 depending on the situation if you want to use
that square for one of your pieces yeah rook a5
is a fun move to play but you always got to make
sure that that knight is not leaving the c6 square
uh as the queen is hitting the a5 square wait
knight f1 uh-oh amman levy had 3.3 seconds left
he has been using all of his time the
clock management has not been a strong suit
of his even in the past match so he needs to speed
up and this position is way too complicated to
have three seconds in yeah i mean all eric has
to do is basically bring rooks to the d file i
would guess like rook d7 rook d8 uh to be honest
the way that he was not playing quickly made me
not maybe think like wait this guy can't have one
second what's going on here rook c8 roxy it wins
the rook on c1 is unprotected and you have to give
your queen that looks like after queen d7 you just
say i have a queen for a rook in one pawn that
should be enough and levy has 1.8 seconds left
bishop h3 though is a move you can count on next
almost you know pre-movable um taking that f5 pawn
i think yeah he's ready for that really nice
move and now you can just take on f5 and the
bishop e6 maybe is sufficient but rook c7 comes
it's a little bit tricky so eric does need to be
careful he should use some of his time here and
absolutely what is the best way to go because
rook c7 then bishop takes f5 it starts looking a
bit problematic for black so maybe even consider
knight takes d6 you are going to lose your knight
but you will lose it you know after bishop f5
queen f5 rook takes d6 you have this bishop on b3
so queen and bishop versus two rooks i think he's
can like yeah i think he's maybe going to play
this he decides to take rook c7 it's gonna happen
um and then just queen d8 yeah that's com um
but maybe he would try d7 there rook takes b7
again it should be winning i think at this point
knight takes d6 is fairly reasonable you already
mentioned it just lose the knight your king's not
getting mated and that bishop and queen should
do damage on the light squares around the king
and one of the big things is that pawn were on
h2 the white king would feel safer but at some
point the move like e3 for black will make the
white king very vulnerable mm-hmm yep and this
this is gonna be too much here there's no more
pin you don't even lose the knight and knight e5
will be game over yeah into those light squares
they go and now there's queen e6 queen h3 with
mate and many checkmates here and went on time
wow i have to say uh robert until you pointed
it out i got lulled into the the same false
sense of security that uh levy maybe got himself
into where what where did that time go we he's
got to be playing way faster there's no way
that the you can just have your time expiring
right in the middle of the well the middle game
that was surprising and levy has struggled with
this in his match against james kent he said it
afterwards he's like i was just moving too slowly
and you cannot afford to have three seconds left
at that point of the game when it's so complicated
what is this knight a3 knight c2 against the
exchange cairo like is is that typical i always
felt you supposed to get your bishop out to f4
which is why uh levy put his queen on c7 before
eric could do that but what's the knight doing on
c2 exactly well it's an interesting movie when you
start with knight a3 uh first of all you threaten
knight b5 and most players are going to play a6
out of instinct if you don't play a6 usually
knight b5 the queen moves and then knight e2
and you're threatening bishop f4 so it's kind
of annoying it makes you waste a move with a6
and then it on c2 after move like e5 is very
well positioned to take over the d4 square
that's right you're over protecting that square
and that's what you want to do when your opponent
has an isolated queen pawn an iqp like the one on
d5 you want to blockade with a knight to d4 often
and then you make sure it can't move then you
start putting pressure on it and try to win it
so right now you don't need to put the knight
in d4 that pawn of course cannot move safely
so i would consider just castling maybe developing
my dark square bishop to f4 and g5 and okay it
goes to f4 this looks like a promising star at
least from my perspective but that's a stylistic
choice and levy's going for activity whereas eric
is the better pawn structure yeah and uh it's not
like one side's better than the other it's that
constant struggle in chess whenever there's an
imbalance both sides are trying to prove that they
have the better side of it so that isolated queen
pond always affords the side with the isolated
pawn a little bit more piece activity control
of the center we see this e4 and c4 squares
both where those knights can jump in and you
know he flipped the board eric rosen on the other
hand you can target that pawn it's going to need
defense constant defense but levy and that great
d4 square that's what you're supposed to do occupy
and control the square in front of the isolated
pawn and look at levi getting active queen to b6
eyeing that b2 pawn you don't really want to give
that pun up but there could be a possibility you
trap the queen if it takes you that's always a
dangerous poison pawn to take so right now eric
trying to figure out do i need to play rook to
b1 that would be the safe move and if eric were
just trying to play speedy chess that's the move
you play instantly okay i'm just defending it
but he could have castled i think because that
queen would have been in no man's land on b2
yeah it's it was definitely maybe possible
especially with black's king still in the middle
but you know what it's the type of position where
you better be safe than sorry so rook b1 covering
the b2 pawn castling's always available and uh you
know white might want to get something like just
h3 in castling and then finally occupy that d4
square with one of his knights and the knight on
c2 is really powerful actually because bishop g4
would be a nice move but then you can play knight
e3 and you're attacking the bishop on g4 and if
the bishop moves to h5 the f5 square that knight
can jump right in there and cause some problem for
black so i'm suddenly appreciating this knight a3
to c2 maneuver and look at that h5 trying to go h4
and go after this bishop and maybe play h3 and pry
open the light squares it's an interesting move
because i feel like h3 for white is so natural i
was going to play it anyway when i see h5 i don't
want to play h4 because of the g4 square so maybe
just h3 and if h4 either bishop back to f4 or
bishop to h2 and um not seeing any issue with that
and eric plays knight to d4 and if black was h4
you cannot play bishop f4 this is a common tactic
there are pieces staring each other those bishops
through the 95 and once that knight takes the
bishop on d3 with check the bishop on f4 would be
hanging for free that tactic doesn't work right
now because the bishops defend so h4 the required
move is bishop takes e5 which i think eric is
okay doing because of this isolated pawn and the
blockade and then he can safely castle his king
yeah safely castles king if queen e2 pinning
the bishop after that black could actually
castle in that position um because there's rookie
eight so it's actually a funny position because
romu 14 robert neither king is castled black's
king could technically still castle queenside
don't expect it but uh for eric rosen i mean we're
expecting short castle sometime in the near future
and counts and queen said there is a common idea
in these types of positions but it's dangerous
right because without the c pawn your king feels
a little less safe though you are the one with
all your pieces over there like the bishops on
d7 and d6 your knight on e5 it feels like maybe
you can get away with it but it does have quite a
bit of risk of course yeah and this bishop i mean
on g3 can drop back to f2 where it's going to put
pressure on the queen on b6 but uh levy's got no
issue playing queen c7 in the near future and
because eric rosen has played f3 uh that h2 pawn
with so you know bishop on d6 queen on c7 is a
something that's really hard to defend you play h3
all of a sudden look at those dark squares
around the king yeah that's not a movie you
really want to see and right now eric thinking so
he is down on the clock levy handling clock much
better at this point he has nearly three minutes
the position remains complicated so you will need
to use that time as the game goes forward and
right now eric's struggling to figure out do i
castle maybe i can make move like bishop f5 that
way i don't have to give up the bishop pair maybe
i'll trade the light square bishops get the f5
square for the knight and he says okay 905 right
away forget about the bishop trade don't really
like this move uh to be honest because uh i'm a
little concerned about the fact that the queen on
b6 uh prevents white from castling and the rook on
b1 means we know that queen side castling is not
happening so i'm concerned about even just mass
trades let's say everything trades e3 f5 g3 in
black just castle safely like i'm concerned about
some positions where uh rosen might not be able
to to get his king there as quickly as he wants
yeah it seems like a bad combination of
moves that you play f3 and then go knight f5
as you're saying the king can't castle the dark
scores of vulnerable a timely bishop f2 could help
you out and right now levy's just trying to figure
out what my partner g7 is under attack the bishop
on d6 is under attack which pieces do i want to
capture do you want to take on d3 first before i
take on f5 should i take on f5 immediately and
you know do i just castle king's side that's
one of the big questions here and i think
he will take on f5 because g7 is hanging and
it looks like it then what's the follow up
though did you just castle king side because
that pawn h5 is starting to bother me yeah
the other option was uh actually taking on g3
and i like the potential idea of keeping the
bishop on d7 so if white ever gets castled or
there's always these ideas like bishop d5 that's
true and he decides to just castle but now viking
castle right bishop takes d6 queen takes e6 and
then quickly castle king's side before the queen
can get back in the diagonal and what about rook
e8 check after bishop d6 i'll probably call bishop
e5 and just say hey i can hoard my pieces i'm
gonna up one here so i will just bring the bishop
right back although that would be two rooks for
a queen possibly yeah in some of these scenarios
and that's a lot to take in that's an interesting
imbalance uh i think that it's probably playable
for both sides uh you know the the evaluation
is very close to you know dead center here
because i think what maybe this is slightly better
for white generally you prefer the rooks but
i think with the queen and the knight that the
knight is crucial uh the fact there's a knight
on the board and that f3 has been played uh i
think i think this is playable for both sides
that's true and the reason why i would prefer the
white side is that d5 pawn is isolated but then i
would prefer the black side because of all these
weak dark squares and the queen can just be such
a nuisance and g6 look at that move included
and if you play queen f4 there was knight d7
and that point was that the pawn couldn't then
defend the bishops the queen g5 is very precise
and if knight d7 now you just play f4 and protect
that bishop with a pawn so there is some danger
that if levy does not take on e5 and give up the
tour for the queen that he may not get his piece
back at least not on even material turns yeah
and i think we're i think we have to see brooke
takes e5 here for those wondering about the queen
for two ropes that robert and i keep referencing
it's going to happen after rook takes e5 queen
takes c5 rook e8 the other rook from the corner
and then the queen will be pinned to the king so
the best course of action looks to be to simply
give it up on e8 followed by bringing in knight
to d4 and then white will be able to castle
but it'll be uh pawns even and just queen for two
rooks so very classic chess and balance i'm on
the time is not even levy's under 30 seconds and
if you are going to give up your rooks for the
queen you can't do it when you have 29 seconds
it just won't be good and now that bishop is
protected that bishop is protected on e5 and
what is black's move here maybe h4 to distract
the queen because f6 is met with queen takes g6
check so he does throw an h4 that's a good move
and after queen f4 now i guess you have f6 as
a way to win that piece back but it's not like
black's king is so thrilled about pushing these
pawns up well remember white can go queen you know
to f4 or f6 like queen d4 something like that and
after rookie five just move the king right it's
not the end of the world and i question whether
you know black is happier uh or white is happier
with the pawns on f6 g6 h4 as you mentioned
like that that could simply just backfire
uh in levees facing with 20 seconds left these
are weaknesses you can't take back no they're not
queen before played and these end games will be
pleasant for white against that isolated pawn he
takes an e5 a check king f2 i think is better he
plays that and queen b5 this to hit the e2 square
i'm not going to allow you to check me there same
with queen e6 rook hd1 and thankfully that knight
on c2 is there that's been a hero piece when all
said done because it protects the e1 square so
the rooks can keep on going use that square
forever yeah and i was just going to say i really
like the idea of getting h3 in it looks like you
know kind of whatever does not a big deal but
the knight is going to eventually come to g5 and
you want to loosen up that king side position with
h3 so the f3 square is weaker white on the other
hand wants to probably get some sort of queen d2
knight d4 in right and what's left is move in
eight seconds you gotta move like it moves like
knight g5 is tempting but you calculate f4 fork in
the rook and knight so then you convince yourself
out of it and now i'd play rook b to d1 remember
that knight on c2 protects the rook on e1 and my
immediate threats go rook takes e5 and queen takes
d5 winning that pawn that problem pawn that's been
there for a while so rook beatty one threatens
just to win material yeah it's it's weird rook
b to d1 it's easy to be deterred by rook e2 check
because you certainly don't want to take that uh
and mate yourself in two moves there is king
f1 available and he decides to take which is
not a decision i would take because look
at the f-file now suddenly knight g5 queen
f6 rook f8 everything seems to be coordinating
and queen five is a great way to start that's a
great move hitting the knight c2 the knight can't
really move because the rook is hanging behind it
if you play rook c1 in comes rook f8 knight g5
and look erika stevens yeah how did that happen
oh my goodness wow the knight g5 rook i faded e4
there's so many good moves here where's knight g5
no knight f6 is too passive and rookie one
played with 2.9 94 check winning material so
it looks like levy's getting this there's a queen
d5 check and he's trying to win some pawns back
for the material but levy blocks the queen f7
this looks like it is levy's game but you got
to move you might lose on time queen f5 is a
great move knight e3 oh the nerves the nerves
yeah we'll see who has the better nerves here
because that's one pawn taking the f3 pawn could
be loose later and neither king is safe oh but if
you trade queens that's got to be a loss yeah the
problem is queen d2 is such a strong threat um and
this is still going to require a conversion here
you know as levy's guardian at f3 pawn but finally
he brings his king and i think that's the way to
go yeah and rook at four now hits the knight
hits both pawns on g4 and on b4 and yeah this is
too many pawns for black and the rook is
too strong yeah just watch out for that
awful fork but rook g2 taking on h2 is going to
seal the deal and a2 would hang next so he moves
the pawn but that h-bone is about to queen so
you have to okay h2 and there's a promotion yeah
and this will be it by the way the time is uh not
enough here and somebody who doesn't resign very
frequently is eric rosen he plays the games out he
gets these tricky stalemates and things like that
but of course levy converts that one nice game
there it was really topsy-turvy at points but levy
he composed himself despite the horrendous time
trouble and he strikes and gets on the scoreboard
and something to remember about this match is uh
there's two sides to every coin robert there's of
course uh levy is putting himself in crazy crazy
time trouble but if there's someone who can get
himself out of this crazy crazy time trouble it's
also levy so you live by this or die by the sword
it's kind of part of his style it's just he plays
a bit slower because he's so confident in his
bullet chest that when you're playing these five
minute games he's like oh okay i got 30 seconds
like he plays 30 seconds chess you know what he's
not gonna feel like 30 seconds is him being low on
time it's only when he's under five seconds
that he really realizes and eric could have
had a similar problem with he had so much extra
time and then he burned it all and suddenly he
was the one who was down on the clock under five
seconds so that was a really nerve-wracking game
and credit to levy for putting all the piece in
the e-file creating some threats and if i'm being
honest that rookie two check i didn't even see it
i should have seen it that the rook had stopped
there but after king f1 as you showed in that
previous game that white was still doing well but
that's why eric took on e5 and levy turned those
tables real quick and was able to launch an attack
yeah and we're already into this next game the
moves are flying uh we have an interesting opening
here where there's a major imbalance basically
black has this b4 square uh has the b file for
himself white is putting pressure on the c file
and definitely has a a slight lead in development
here ideas like knight e5 and knight b5 come to
mind maybe bishop f4 targeting the c7 pawn so hey
what about the move c5 uh looking to trade the c
pawn for the center pawn and all things considered
structurally i think black is doing well black has
a really nice looking position and one important
thing is the pawn's an a7 because if one of the
white pieces wants to go the b5 square you can
play a6 like if the knight gets in there to kick
it out whereas that b4 square that's an outpost
white does not have a pawn that can kick any of
black's pieces out and so rook coming to b8 soon
it looks like it can be very promising for eric
and he is a bit ahead on the clock we're gonna
say this often it feels like in the match but
he already has a lead of almost 30 seconds and
if he can maintain that with the strong central
pawn structure he has that pawn on d5 really good
one then he should have the upper hand as this
game continues yeah and uh takes on c5 here and
the reason that you know uh the evaluation maybe
is hovering a little bit closer to the middle
uh there 0.00 is probably because that bishop's
not quite developed yet for mr rosen so there's
you know knight d4 ideas knight b5 ideas and
sometimes there's even and i was about to say
it the move e4 and you do this because that bishop
is not quite developed yet and you you burst the
center wide open and who's going to benefit uh
when the center opens up robert it's going to be
the guy who's the lead in development although
one way to kind of counter that development
bishop a6 right now because you played e4 my
bishop can develop and attack your rook on f1
and if you have to move your rook to e1 then i
get a turn maybe queen b6 hitting the f2 pawn
it could be some danger there and eric does play
bishop a6 and i'm expecting levy to e takes d5
sacrifice in exchange rip open the position and
let the bishops fly free but that's a risky move
when you have to give up material yeah it's a
uh it's something to consider because the other
option rookie one he's probably looking at the
move queen b6 and saying wait a minute how do i
you know defend f2 because after queen b6 let's
not forget that e pawn is going to be hanging the
bishop pinning the knight on f6 to the queen after
queen b6 remember that pin is not there anymore
that's right and knight g4 moves happen fast
before you know it f2 falls so that could be
very dangerous and levy trying to figure this out
he can go knight b5 as well to block that bishop's
attack of the rook but then the e4 pawn is really
without defenders so that looks pretty risky so
i don't know like the way he's thinking it makes
it hard for me to you know tie together thinking
and giving up the material so he does play knight
to b5 which gives up the pawn with d takes e4 but
there are going to be tactics with the knight
pinned on f6 the bishop one c5 a bit loose the
knight on d7 doing kind of the hero's work right
now covering everything yeah absolutely knight b5
i think was probably a decent decision because i
did not like the look of rookie one queen b6 and
uh you know going into that position he would
have to expect to give up the exchange if you're
not prepared to do that it's not a decision
you can make just you know on the fly yeah so
we see that d64 is happening now the knight can
move to d2 but even e3 is a possibility for black
like when you win a pawn sometimes you just push
it and try to create a worse pawn structure for
your opponent that's a great point and the other
thing that is involved with that e3 idea is that
black does not care about bishop takes a8 you
know in a lot of positions that that bishop on g2
is probably levi's best piece and you give that up
look how weak the white king is going to be so e3
definitely a consideration here you know queen b6
can can happen all the same but e3 looks like the
kind of fun testing move right i like e3 it
just hurts your opponent's pawn structure and
that's all i'm looking for and if that bishop
were to leave g5 that bishop and c5 can take on
e3 with check in some lines so there's a lot
to calculate especially with that rook and
hanging but i'm kind of willing to sacrifice that
rook everything opens up i haven't calculated
fully but i feel like black should not be unhappy
about that kind of transition yep um he's thinking
a lot here so rosen is investing his time back
into the position knight d2 played i wonder
what else he could be thinking of because queen
maybe b6 is the only thing but knight takes e4
just it looks like a move you don't want to allow
it hits the bishop on c5 and if you play knight
takes e4 there's bishop takes e4 hitting the rook
in the corner the queen will then be hitting the
knight on d7 so that's all stuff for rosen to
consider yeah that opening of the position favors
a bishop on the longest diagonal the bishop one g2
you're pointing out the bishop on c8 wasn't doing
much the bishop on a6 perhaps not doing as much
either except for being captured knight and e3
was played here so that hits the knight on d2 he
immediately takes back and i think i would consid
i would really consider taking that knight on b5
because it's just bothering me and then putting my
rook on b8 but then that c6 square we've seen
this happen in previous matches where there's
a pawn on b5 a bishop getting into c6 and that
could be really annoying rook c8 is a nice move
that deals with a lot of things at once it deals
with obviously the rook being hit in the corner
and it adds some support to the bishop you might
be thinking you know why is that such a big deal
well there's a pin on this knight on f6 and if the
knight on d7 were to take back suddenly would be
undefending the bishop on c5 so it's just adding
an extra defender to this bishop so the knight on
d7 is free to move to f6 if need be because moves
like knight e4 uh or potentially on the horizon
yes and well h6 would be a big threat for black
right because then you remove the defender of the
e3 pawn and that punk can be taken with check so
h6 is the simple threat how do we deal with that
and maybe we have to protect this e3 pawn but
if you play move like queen e2 you're walking
into a new pin that could be awkward knight c4
looks strong because you protect e3 and uh you
also open the d file for your pieces but i'm
already looking at knight to b6 let's trade off
knights let's try to get that e3 pawn and i feel
like white's pawn structure is just worse here
yeah knight to knight b6 it looks like maybe i'd
consider knight d6 there i thought actually white
was gonna play knight e4 hitting the bishop
and taking advantage of the pin the move h6
we were talking about did happen and if bishop
f4 he already has to think about g5 e5 but he's
saying look with my new move knight c4 bishop
d6 is the idea there's an amazing line that i'm
just realizing based on your 94 move i think that
eric would have sacrificed his queen with knight
takes e4 so we can show that in the analysis board
where just a move ago if uh instead of knight c4
uh if knight e4 was played that would have been
a queen sack i believe that would be a fun one
bishop takes d8 and bishop takes e3 with the rook
hanging on c1 ideas like knight f2 in the position
you know bishop d8 later that would be a fun one
yeah that would have been really cool but i think
levy he sniffed that one out he's like this
doesn't feel right let's go for something a little
more solid and eric says no solidity for you i'm
pushing my pawn to e5 and guess what that bishop
on four it's not going to be protecting this
pawn on e3 much longer if we trade knights on e5
down goes up pawn e3 with check and that rook on
c1 is under attack it feels like eric's about to
win some material yep e5 is a nice uh move that
basically everything is going to get clarified in
the center white's king is going to be a little
bit weak and bishop e3 we just saw the the line
where you know the rook on c1 was threatened
with the bishop and the rook what are you even
supposed to do here um asking the wrong guy uh the
video on f4 is under attack i was going to say can
you throw in b4 and he does do that but it feels
like this take on f4 and then maybe even take him
capturing stuff and the pawn c5 at
the end of this is going to be hanging
right yeah i think that bishop takes b4 plays into
levy's hands like that's the intention of the move
um and wow what a what a poised move there bishop
b6 he says look that apon is not able to move to
a5 to continue harassing me the bishop is going to
take the knight on b5 in that case and if you take
me well there's so many things that are going to
be hanging in your position after queen takes b6
the bishop's trapped on f4 it's strapped in the
center of the board it has no three squares to
go to so what a restrained move by eric and now
does rook take c1 and e takes f4 you win a piece
yeah just plain and simple um there's nothing
to do here e3 is still weak still pinned i mean
that's the one of the cleanest pieces you'll
ever see with knight g4 following this up
yeah and look at the clock five seconds left
for levy so he knows he's in trouble eric
he's seizing the momentum here in this match
he won the first game levy evened it now again
with the black pieces if eric can convert this
it'll be the third win with black in the match
yeah and this has got to be a
conversion four seconds up a full piece
uh i mean 50 seconds for you what more could
you ask for yeah if you don't win this game
that's going to be really upsetting you know you
it's hard to come back from these moments and we
have seen this in previous matches where a player
just really botches it but here what's the best
way because knight c6 looks a little annoying
now this bishop takes e3 check after knight c6
but you can also the queen takes a 5. you can take
that knight first and then take on e3 so it's your
just for style points but it looks like nobody's
needing them here b5 though will be played
and i think the the easiest is bishop b7 it looks
it looks funny because you're walking into maybe
97 check but the rook was guarding that from e3
that's right now the trade of bishops can happen
the rook should probably go on over to the a3
square there it goes the b pawn can't move the 97
now knight b6 probably just scoops up the a4
pawn i believe so uh knight b6 now same idea
yes bringing both knights over and it's a win
on time but it was a win on the board as well
exactly yeah and uh that's going to be a recurring
thing i think the the time situation robert it's
constantly going to be uh what looks like from the
match so far it's going to be levied down on time
but ever resourceful and you can just never
count them out no you cannot and we get our
halftime break through the five minute plus one
second increment portion it is two to one eric
players winning with the black pieces so
aman let me ask you something we we get to
take a few minutes they get to prepare look over
lines what do these players need to do to start
winning with the first move image yeah it's funny
i think that might just be nerves starting out um
i actually haven't liked the positions that uh
levy has gotten so far with the catalan it's it
felt like uh eric was really dictating the pace
so he might look to switch up his opening we know
he's a very accomplished london system player as
well like these guys can play a bunch of different
openings uh it happens when you stream a lot you
often experiment so i think that we might see some
openings uh being changed when we come back yeah
i think they need to play a little more solidly
they're allowing black way too much activity
in these positions and kings getting unsafe
and things of that nature but we'll see we'll be
back in a few minutes for more action from this
gotham chest i am rosen i am now gm speechless
championship match brought to you by chess.com
and we returned ready for more five-minute plus
one second increment blitz amman the players have
gotten the time to have a breather they can
stretch a little bit say the nerves all right
i know that we were playing we were giving each
other chances but now that a couple games are
underway what do you think what can the players do
differently how do you see this match continuing
yeah i think uh so far what we've seen is a lot
of time pressure and it's a tough thing to adjust
to because it's sort of stylistic you either
are a person who gets a long time or you're not
but i think that levy if it continues the way that
we've seen so far he might quickly identify that
as sort of like a lose condition like something
that he just simply has to change or has to fix
we saw him do a lot better um at playing under
time pressure he turned around an entire game in
beautiful fashion got right back in the match but
going forward i think he's going to have to pick
openings that he can play a little bit quicker at
the beginning so that you know eric rosen isn't
sort of playing an offbeat line and sort of knows
the entire opening and gets a one to two minute
time advantage for no reason that's true and
here we see a karo khan and another exchange so
generally speaking this is seen as a very solid
position where there are not as many tactical
lines and if levy goes for this e5 push again
he'll be left with the isolated queen pawn so
it looks like eric plays h3 which is thematic
taking away anything to g4 and that's already a
big difference between this and the previous game
yep you can tell like players are going to use
these brakes for different reasons sometimes you
don't want to look at any chest during the break
the best thing for you might just be to you know
take drink relax uh calm yourself down and some
players like to hop right on the the computer
check their analysis and say look we might be
playing this line the whole match it's worth it
for me to check on some of the main lines and h3
looks like an improvement that he came back with
and he's already coming out very quickly look
he's got more time than he started with robert
yeah and levi has already spent 40 seconds and
this is a better version of what we saw in game
two and the reason why instead of having a pawn
on f3 you have a knight on f3 and your pawn's
on h3 so there are those dark square problems
you still have the blockade against this pawn on
d5 and this is how you tend to play now black's
position isn't that bad i don't want to make
it sound like levy's done anything wrong he
has not it's a standard position i just have
a strong preference stylistically of playing
against the isolated queen pawn because you need
activity you have the e file is open the c file is
semi-open for your rooks but you're a bit behind
in uh in terms of development white can bring a
rook in first and then bring the bishop out and
that pawn on d5 especially after bishop g5 oman
that feels like the pawn is quite weak yeah
and there's something about this position
i almost prefer it to the last game that levy
played with this opening just having those two
bishops sometimes you can even lose this pawn on
d5 just get all the open files maybe b5 bishop b7
the rook's come to come to the middle of the board
and yeah he plays h6 he's saying look bishop takes
f6 i'm going to take back and feel free to take
my pawn on d5 all of a sudden it's going to be
moves after moves with tempo although the problem
is bishop f6 bishop 6 knight b4 you can actually
try to win that pawn with your knight and that
causes black more problems so he instead retreats
his bishop to h4 which is fine the bishop can go
to g3 as well and you could take on f6 at some
moment but right now queen b6 levy he's timing
these moves very well hitting this pawn on b2
yep and definitely after queen b6 i think it's
going to be a rook b1 consideration however you
mentioned it last time queen takes b2 rook f to
b1 and that is going to be a trapped queen however
rook e1 hits the bishop if bishop c5 hitting f2
i mean the queen watches over the knight on f6
yes and so now do you just play bishop e6 which
is not a move you like to play because the knight
wants to blockade the pawn anyway and if your
bishop sitting on e6 you defend the pawn and d5
but now your bishop on e6 is under attack and
then you have to think is my opponent going
to capture me there so i think levy already
has a tough choice here he does play bishop
e6 and i'm looking at knight f to d4 because i
want my knight on c2 potentially go to e3 later
right um and i think there's there's an
interesting move i've been looking at
i'm not quite sure if it works but knight e4 um
giving up the e7 bishop for some sort of queen f2
um shenanigans down there don't know if it worked
but definitely looked a little bit unnecessary in
the position uh knight d4c to d4 just played which
means in general you have to watch out for that b2
pawn now that there is queen a3 to escape that's
right and your 94 idea that's actually pretty
interesting something that levy if he gets time
after uh this series of games for the next break
he can look into that but that's really deep into
these openings probably too far down the line to
think about too much but it's hard move to play
because that bishop on e7 would have been hanging
but anyway that's behind us the knights on d4
blocking that queen's access to f2 but as you
just said the pawn on b2 is a problem so rookie
2 comes to mind uh i don't really want to play
rook a1 to b1 that feels like too passive of a
way to defend that pawn whereas rook e2 a to e1
now we're talking getting my rooks onto the open
file yeah rookie 2 rook 81 looks uh like the best
uh way to do this because it also adds pressure
on e6 and e7 those two bishops lined up there
i'm actually kind of curious how black is going
to meet that it might be with that move knight e4
now that the bishop is defended on e7 if one of
the hardest questions to answer is do you take
on e6 and i'm much more likely to take on e6 when
black's pawn is on h6 rather than h7 because the
g6 squares a little bit vulnerable but instead
eric does play the calm the cool collective move
rookie two and his plan is pretty natural right
just rookie two rookie one and for levi i think
now is the time to strike whether it's knight to
e4 there's also knight h5 which is just a tricky
move trying to get your knight to f4 with the
fork but he needs to act because he can't sit
on this position much longer yeah and i was just
gonna say we we've reached a middle game position
you can see the eval bar right around the middle
there knight h5 your move played knight f4 you
have to watch out for it but i think this is good
from levi he's keeping pace you know the time is
not an issue but we have seen him just kind of
randomly tank about a minute in a regular position
like this if he avoids that he can find moves you
know knight h5 look how quickly he played that
it's a great move he just needs to trust himself
it's also a great realization recognition that
last one was rookie e2 so something has changed
knight h5 if that rook on e1 would not be a
particularly good move but because you have the
fork available to you it creates this tactical uh
possibility and now the bishops are staring each
other down bishop takes e7 is a blunder because of
knight f4 and knight takes e2 with check before
taking that bishop back so i think that white
needs to move the queen and probably queen d2 but
queen c2 is also a move i don't know what you want
to pick yeah the interesting thing about queen you
know d2 to watch the f4 square is that levy might
just sidestep next move play bishop d6 control
the f4 square say look your bishop on h4 is doing
absolutely nothing now there's no there's no pin
there's nothing to hit and you can't even go back
to g3 because i've got that covered that's a good
call and he takes an e6 which covers the f4 square
so at least that's protected against but what if i
just take back on e6 which i have to do f takes e6
and then knight f4 is a renewed threat the rook
on f8 is very happy to get that semi-open file and
there could be tactics as well with like a rook
takes f3 at some point there's lots of renewed
threats in that case remember if the bishop
goes back to g3 it's always a free piece as well
uh because the queen on b6 is pinning that f2 pawn
you mentioned ideas like rook takes f3 might not
work exactly here but keep that in mind as a way
to remove the knight from defending the bishop on
h4 so yeah i mean you just called it knight f4 to
cap it off there are so many threats here that uh
eric has to deal with and levy is now up on time
and seems to be taking over the the game slowly if
eric had a bit of time you know knight e5 knight
g6 taking over those vulnerable light squares
that would be nice you just don't have that
time knight h5 was such a good move by levy
and queen d4 i think bishop c5 knight f4 to
follow bring all of my pieces in for the attack
levy he's doing well on the clock and doing
better on the board so i think that this is
his chance to even the match definitely bishop
c5 is very very natural here um i guess there is
a you know a world for queen takes d4 um keep in
mind queen d4 pawn d4 rook takes f3 white's gonna
throw in bishop takes on uh e7 or even maybe a
tricky rook takes e6 in that position so um for
example queen takes take with the pawn let's say
something like rook takes f3 i mean this is a wild
calculation but it's probably uh something
that these players are considering robert
ryan your bishop takes e7 was important i would
say instead of taking on f3 which loses the bishop
and then it's a knight against a bishop the bishop
not great the knight can hop around the board but
that's we'll save that for those classical books
that we read about we're going to get something
more tactical here with bishop five i know it i
i'm sure like especially after a long think like
this you almost have to keep that that bishop in
play there we go we do see bishop c5 stylistically
i think that suits levy even more use that open
f file and is it going to be knight f4 here or
just knight back to f6 knight f4 played and the
rook needs to scoot on over you need to keep an
eye on the f2 pawn i'd say so rook to d2 and i'm
already looking at moving h5 for black the point
being that queen on g4 is running out of squares
quite quickly it's pretty dangerous position so
where is that queen going after hrv i guess
you have queen g3 but then bishop d6 renewing
the threat of a discovery against that queen and
it really is running out of options yeah and it
you know if i even show something like queen to
g5 rook f5 is one of the ideas bishop d6 we see
that queen nearly getting trapped there and you
know ideas like knight e2 eric just can't develop
that rook on f1 or a1 robert and levy played
h5 so he's seen all the tactics and right now
it's about even the clock levy a little bit ahead
but his position is so much better but i will say
now that we're getting into that bullet stretch of
this game mistakes do happen much more commonly so
you think you have a winning tactic and you miss
the fourth move down the line and all of a sudden
things go wrong i think levy has this he's been in
control for a large part of the game right now but
it's still tricky especially when you're pawn's
on h5 and your king side's a little bit open
yeah and i'm i'm wondering how how we're supposed
to stop this robert it's almost like king h1
is one of the only moves just get in the corner
and strangely enough this knight maybe doesn't
have any completely winning moves that's true king
each one and then you're so frustrated as black
because i have to have a winning move and then you
have to realize wait there's no win on this turn
but my position is better because my pieces are
coordinated really well so what that move is right
now i don't know w what piece needs to be improved
should i put my queen somewhere else should i play
e5 but e5 has risk because then the d5 pawn is
looser not an easy situation right now for black
despite having the about evaluation lead as we
see on screen here it just isn't that easy to play
not at all i actually like the move e5 it's risky
but i think the position almost calls for e5 e4
knight d3 uh sync that knight in and then just
just play from there at the end of the day
you can't calculate a perfect variation here
it's frustrating enough that there's no wind
on the spot i think just mobilize the center
and you know it's frustrating because look levi
spent a lot of time and now we're at even time
and i saw the eval bar it went back up better
for white all of a sudden knight d4 hits the work
with tempo and this is exactly what happens in a
bullet stretch of a game yeah and queen g6 after
a night move like knight e2 keeping my queen g6
it's gonna hit the rook on e8 there's so many
things happening and moves are flying in quick
as a flash now robert okay and if i play that
pawn is pins you're not actually threatening the
knight on d4 maybe there's a move thrown he plays
bishop g5 for that reason and look at levy quickly
renewing the discovery against the queen
queen for it now take on f4 take on h5
is possible in some variations le'veon
in eight seconds he's now down on time
maybe bishop ba queen d6 an idea that go for
h2 mate he doubles rooks on the f file and now
we're gonna have to see eric getting under
10 seconds this is going to be a wild finish
it is radiation you have to play the quickly the
h5 punting look at queen h6 g5 g5 will trap the
queen that's a win on the spot he has to play f3
it's not a move you want to play and no replay
he's threatening g5 again queen he won he freed
up the square and all of a sudden levy's thinking
2.7 seconds the queen comes back to e1 and now
queen b1 and look at this it's turning around
yeah bishop f4 and queen g3 though he wins
in exchange this is not over though bishop f4
keep that e3 pawn queen d5 king h8 oh my gosh
but you have the palm but rook to d1 take over
that open file you have rooks use them and queen
somewhere are you just going to figure out where
to knock him out in 1.3 seconds both of these
players are just almost losing on the spot queen
d4 check rook d7 coming up yep queen d5 check
queen careful queens wait trade every one of me
because robert all he had to do was play queen
takes f7 with a check queen f7 check he needed
to take the rook but he took it the wrong way
and what a move by levy rosman and let's show
that finish one more time let's bring up the
uh analysis board there because you needed to
trade the queens off you saw before it happened
that queen b won checkmate but queen takes f7
wins for white just look at that eval bar it goes
after rook f7 all the way up queen takes f7 needed
to be played here black would be forced to trade
because it's a check but the wrong piece captured
first and that's why order matters in chess look
at that eval bar all the way down robert and queen
b1 found by levy wow and that can turn the entire
match around for levy here he played a very good
game he was alert he was pressing forward and he
started off very well on the clock then things
got out of hand and well i hate to say i called it
but we were getting that point where he's getting
the bullet and all of a sudden it's difficult
to find the knockout you're getting frustrated
you play a little bit slowly and then eric was
timely he struck back with 96 winning exchange
and finally in a pure time scramble it was levy
on top there just finding queen bee one track
a lot of credit to both of those players after a
hard fought game and wait d5 is a pawn sacrifice
yeah i was gonna say this is actually a well-known
uh ponzac in this line um the move e3 i don't
think is very good because of it i mean it's not
winning on the spot or anything but it's just a
nice way to get developed and uh usually black
is pretty happy to to get that move in yeah the
one downside in black's position is the e5 pawn
a little bit loose and that knight on d5 now is
not defended but if you take knight takes e5
the bishop recaptures and the queen opens up
to that knight that would be a blunder by white
even though it looks like you might be winning a
pawn yeah and i think both players are are going
to try to solve their their problems here just
castling bishop e6 now a move that always hurts
bishop e6 it moves like knight g5 and that's
what makes me think of e4 and play quickly by
levy if pawn takes on e4 we're gonna see the
knight jump into g5 hitting the bishop and then
looking to take back on e4 maybe with a piece
keep in mind there's queen h5 check queen b3
so many ideas i like white's position after e4
and part of the problem with this opening is
that knight on d5 it went knight c6 knight b4
knight takes d5 that takes time and the king is
still in the center white's king is castled and
black's position's a bit flimsy here so knight
g5 coming as you've been talking about the light
squares are very vulnerable and i think that eric
he kind of has to just say all right this doesn't
look good but let me take on e4 and when you go
knight g5 i'll just play queen e7 and you'll take
my bishop i won't be happy about it but at the
very least i'll have the ability to castle next
and i'm not down any material yeah that's a great
point and already in the tank here uh is rosen
although the time's actually even it looks like
levy was taking his time earlier with that tricky
d5 move so both players investing in the opening
we actually have seen the opening phase of this
match robert has really taken a long time i think
that is partly because rosen does play so many
tricky sidelines it's just his style that i think
both players in general are going to be investing
time in the opening because levy wants to make
sure that he's not misstepping in any of these
offbeat lines and it's the first time we've seen
white with a good position on the opening because
we've had four wins by black and the openings have
looked good for the black pieces this is the first
real advantage with the white pieces that i
can recall absolutely and and it's a very real
advantage um after knight g5 i mean it already
comes to question are we playing bishop g8 to
keep the bishop that's the move that comes to
mind that's the first instinct but it's not clear
that you can get away with that because you're
not going to be castling kingside there give so
much time to your opponent right so queen e7 eric
says i have to i'll give up that bishop take it
my queen takes at least my center is protected i
can try to castle queen side and if you take on e4
with the pawn your bishop on g2 could actually be
a bystander to plenty of the action in this game
so you prefer to take with the bishop on e4 but
that leaves that pawn on d3 as an isolated pawn
and that could be a problem in and of itself
so it's not an easy decision for levy either
definitely um i think there's like queen a4 queen
takes e4 if you want to play that way black won't
be too upset though to play um c6 and maybe long
castle or short castle there so i think levy is
just definitely better it looks like he does
want to play queen a4 and maybe take back with
the queen on e4 another situation where it's clear
that white is better but a few moves from now that
advantage can go away and in part it's because
this decision right now you have three pieces
all those captured in e4 look pleasant for white
but then you say is it really that bad for black
you said castle king side why not give that seve
open file maybe my bishop will come to c5 at some
moment and i can attack your pawn on f2 and all
of a sudden i like my isolated pawn e5 just like
the iqp we had in other positions look at queen b3
threatening the b7 pawn threatening to go d takes
e4 and perhaps black says all right i'll give you
b7 and i'm taking you on d3 and now we get a wild
tactical game yeah it makes me question like what
what's the call your bluff move is it pawn takes
on d3 queen b7 short castle queen takes c6 e4
and just saying look i'll take the entire center
you get my entire queen side that center if it
falls apart it's gg but if he hangs on to that
that could be levy spoiling his advantage although
i like what eric just did because while e takes d3
could have worked look at that bishop on g2 not
the happiest bishop that we've seen especially
when you have two bishops advantage a queen trade
not so bad for black your rooks are connected can
take over the d files so i think all things
considered eric is very happy to get to this
position out of the opening where it looked
like he could lose tactically in a few moves
absolutely um i think this game is going to come
down to the dark squares if this bishop manages
you know to put itself on d4 for example it's
going to be looking at the f2 pawn the b2 pawn
and it's going to be very very strong but bishop
e3 that's why he played h3 keep that move in mind
he didn't just play for no reason knight g4 would
have been the same annoyance as knight g5 earlier
in this game attacking the bishop but played
h3 stopped it now he takes over this important
important diagonal and that that's why i think
that levy's doing well here and he does it with
tempo that palm a7 is now under attack if the
rook run a8 so if that rook on f8 went to d8
do you play your idea bishop c7 bishop b6 and try
to trade off those dark square bishops but now the
pawn a7 is under attack so you don't have time
to just make a random move otherwise white will
capture so if you play a6 then a bishop plants
itself on b6 and takes over the dark squares there
that's not so bad for black and a bishop trade the
darts are bishop trade could be nice because that
bishop on g2 isn't in the game but giving up those
holes on the queen side isn't exactly appealing
absolutely the the dark squares here are gonna
shape the game and levy up a minute on the clock
it's like where have we seen this before well
not in this match so far robert white has a
good position and levy's up a minute on the clock
yeah and eric has really been struggling in this
game and it's because he did kind of the opening
surprise and then levy just parried it off really
well and now eric trying to find the precise
moves you need to make the good moves quickly not
the best move slowly we always say this and right
now bishop c7 is played giving up that pawn in a7
that [ __ ] what do you think robert basically
it comes down to do you have it in you to take
it because i think we can all look at
this pawn and say that's greedy but
it's takeable yeah i think you should capture it
and what eric's really relying on is not a bishop
trap i think he wants to trade the bishops and
he says i'll give you that outside rook pawn if i
trade the bishops i'll take over the dark squares
in particular the d4 square it takes a while for a
knight to get there but if that knight could go f6
to e6 and into d4 then we're talking yeah uh still
a crucial decision because that's a way to
hang the match right there you know what
i mean or at least hang this game bishop a7 if
you miscalculate something believe me what he's
looking at is bishop a7 b6 and then queen takes
c6 and you know like there follows maybe a rook d6
or something like that and that bishop does stay
locked on a7 for longer than feels comfortable
and i'm sure that levy doesn't believe in it he
knows that he can take the pawn a7 he's checking
double checking unfortunately quadruple checking
because he gets himself in some time trouble
but he does take the pawn so he makes the right
decision he spent a minute and four seconds
to figure it out but um eric had spent a minute
and 17 seconds on his move so both players spent a
lot of time and eric just goes rook 8 i guess the
a2 pawn can be captured but bishop c5 with tempo
8 pawn is saved and that totally worked out for
levy time invested and paid off immediately that
you wonder about the similarities between chess
and poker well robert that was called a bluff
bishop c7 i think eric rosen knew that pawn could
be taken but just hoping that the the calculations
would scare off levy but you know levy says all
right let's go you want to calculate that i'm
right there with you and i believe he calculated
it very well let's see if he can convert his one
pawn advantage as we mentioned those dark square
bishops now being traded off fantastic decision by
eric you're down a pawn you realize that my knight
can outclass a bishop especially that light square
bishop so if you trade the bishops levy says no
don't want any part of that but now the f2 pawn
so rook f8 the problem is not solved because that
bishop can plant itself on d4 he plays knight f6
still that bishop can come to d4 and how is white
going to make progress you have an extra pawn
but it's this f2 pawn that's really where your
extra pawn is right now you're not moving that
because i can get your king in trouble and so it's
not so clear how to proceed i like that decision
by levy i would go f4 here and he's played it
king h2 just like get the king out of the way
i know that i can't trade these bishops so you
know what i'm going to give you this great d4
square we talked about it earlier and i think
bishop h4 could be played here and he saves the
bishop g5 not possible because the f4 pawn is
right there but you're not going to take on e5
and then the bishop takes back on e5 and that's a
great square so in comes the queen say please take
my knight and f6 i don't mind opening my king
because you don't have pieces to attack me and
it's your king on h2 on that dark square that can
get in some trouble and it's tough decision after
tough decision for levy right now do you play f5
that closed down the position he says no bishop
f3 let's attack the queen you're gonna drop back
the g6 and now do i play f5 that's f5 with tempo
that's always a little bit more enticing i think
queen queen b3 i was actually wondering on the
last move was it gonna happen because it sort of
makes the move queen h5 look a little questionable
oh and now if you don't trade queens is black
gonna take on f4 and say hey you take with your
pawn your king is not feeling so safe i would take
on f4 i'm down to pawn but i'm going for your kick
ef4 g for bishop e3 threading rook d2 when he
plays bishop v3 first rook d2 is the threat
yep it's got to be rook well you feel like it's
got to be rook d1 but hey that that pawn can now
be taken there's an e5 flurry you know in the
position but i just don't think it quite works
for levy no because you can take on d1 and then
move your knight you got out of the pin by trading
and this is why i didn't like f4 your king
is exposed you're creating threats for black
now black has all of this out seven seconds
for white you gotta go you gotta now knight d5
your pawn forward defend f63 is a big threat
because the rook on f1 is not defended the king
is in a big trouble here f takes g3 king g2 and
then bishop c2 g5 just trapped the bishop there
there's still some tricks here though queen f6 is
a solid move g takes h4 okay that's going to be
in there queen h7 that was sneaky though and just
rookie yeah the fisherman e3 is protected so queen
e7 here pick up the pawn and the king on jade
can live to see another day this is not gonna be
enough um and you know he's gonna try here but uh
i don't think we're gonna see anything other than
eric rosen converting this position he's got an
extra piece and a pawn to boot what a wild game it
looked like levy had a big advantage and then eric
played good defense and the position opened up
unfavorable terms for levy now eric can just push
his f pawn he puts his king in he's trying to go
for a checkmate if he got a rook p5 bishop f2 mate
so that's why the king ran away and now his f-pawn
can start running yeah and this uh you know it's
levy who has the one second you know in rook f5
trying for something you know hoping for f3
pre-move or something like that good try that
was a good try and we still have 16 minutes
45 seconds left in this longest time control
and i'm not sure who prefers to play more games
because it has felt very back and forth black has
won all five games okay so maybe they should start
playing a3 on the first move and try to play with
just hand the move over i agree because even with
that opening advantage that we saw there robert it
just can't break the curse that black is winning
every single game it okay d4 a fun position with
white is it gonna matter well let's find out
robert can white finally win a game in this match
and this variation is interesting i'm not quite
sure why eric went away from the positions he
was getting with the iqp that isolated queen
pawn i thought they were pleasant for white
but perhaps eric didn't feel like they were in
his comfort zone and instead we're getting a
more open position look at this the bishop on
d3 is open now the bishop d6 of course is open
knight takes d4 there could be bishop takes h2
check as a possibility with queen h4 to follow
that's a known tactical sequence which means
that the pawn d4 could be potentially untouchable
yeah and i i always wonder in positions like this
uh if rosen is really planning to take it back
right away or if he's sort of going for something
more attacking knight takes d4 looks tempting is
it worth saving this bishop uh something like c5
you can already keep the extra pawn but i think
that might be exactly what rosen is looking
for it reminds me of these openings where
freaking exactly what move it is but it's like
the italian with an early d4 and a sacrifice we
try to like bishop g5 and give up the pawn and go
for an attack that shouldn't work out with proper
play but it's always scary and instead levy says
i don't want to deal with that let me just develop
my pieces i'm doing fine i'm up a pawn right now
my bishop pins your knight so you can't even get
the d4 pawn but i would probably play h3 and just
try to get the bishop pair yep yeah h3 um looks
like a good move to start with uh no matter what
you know if the bishop goes to h5 you deal with
that after knight takes dc because bishop h7 check
of queen takes d6 so you have to take on f3 wow
what a move yeah we can show that for everybody
just what a nice little tactic yeah so knight
takes c6 queen takes d6 i mean that's a move
you pretty much pre-move nearly um here and then
knight g5 check and queen takes g4 and hey you
pick that up the g4 pawn is still loose in the
position there's still ideas like queen to the h
file and queen h7 mate yes and it would be even
material so i think that's what levy's trying to
figure out here because he can give the h7 pawn or
he can take on f3 and then give up two bishops
keep his material and say i have the knights
and extra pawn but you have these bishops my king
could still be vulnerable i would i wouldn't want
to give the bishop but i don't want to give the
h7 pawn so he does take on f3 and i think that's
the best choice and do you think there's also a
little bit of ego like you don't want to let the
guy play bishop to h7 on you you're like oh i see
the tactic i can't let him uh do me like that on
chess tv yeah that's probably part of it you know
there are what uh 18 000 people here on twitch and
you know more on youtube and elsewhere on chess
tv everyone's watching so i know bishop h7 for
you and instead we have this position what is
white's follow-up though because how do you really
start making creating pressure that's the thing
you can get away with you know having the bishops
and that sounds good but then you have to prove
it like where are you going from here the proof
is always the hard part i think in general you
know move like bishop d2 or a3 is almost needed uh
i'm a little concerned about knight d7 knight e5
or knight b4 in general taking these pieces out
of the way knight f6 looks so natural but i think
he he wanted that to follow up with bishop g5 and
try to get a rook lift maybe i think eric's just
relying on counter play and activity and even
though knight b to d7 that final night is out the
rooks are connected black should be happy up upon
you just see these bishops and you have to concern
yourself if i ever play h6 is he just gonna sack
that bishop on h6 and rip with my king and so
how do i yeah how do i shield myself but the
simple answer is probably move your queen away
because under attack then bring your rook to e8
go with the open file and just play it slowly be
deliberate you don't have to rush any decisions
here absolutely um keep in mind queen d5 i know
it sounds crazy but it's hitting that a2 pawn so
if all the rooks go to e8 we might see a situation
where you can almost take that and just grab
a2 and say look you know i prove your advantage i
like that rook 81 queen takes a2 is a possibility
and if i am eric i'm probably ready to give that
up like i'll play b3 trap your queen over there
for a while and try to get some kind of quick play
but you are down one pawn going down two not ideal
yeah that's a good point queen d5 just a nice
centralizing movement life is just putting the
question back to eric we see the time situation
b3 played because hey he saw that a pawn and let's
keep in mind levy actually took the pawn on e7 so
i think rosen is probably thinking i don't think
i can bluff him twice in the same match and once
again black has a good position now the opening
up the engine right we see the evaluation bar it
agrees and the thing about b3 which is tricky is
there's some bishop c4 not to be so afraid of but
at some moment the f7 square could be a target so
i think that's why levy's taking his time but rook
fte that's the sort of the obvious move to him but
he's trying to say maybe i switch my a rook over
maybe that's the precise way to go and the only
downside of playing 88 is if i get bishop d6
if i can remove your queen then your rook on
f8 is trapped over there so there is something
to figure out yeah i was thinking another like
main idea that sometimes black goes for is queen
h5 with the idea queen g3 queen g4 now don't know
if we want to do that exactly in this moment but
it's actually a way to force the queens off the
board for sure and when you're up upon you always
want to be looking for ways to possibly do that
there's a great tactical sequence right now bishop
e5 queen e5 rook 81 and yeah the queen of d6
afterwards and you can play the move rookie seven
i've actually experienced this in a game where my
opponent has done that to me and i was shocked
but the point is that the queen takes e7 bishop
takes h7 and the knight can't capture you back so
someone has done this not in this exact position
but i have faced this before and i've stored that
in the memory bank of hey wait a sec that knight
on f6 is pinned and it would only be a draw in
that case but that's just the type of thing that
scares you you know if you're calculating yeah and
like i said i missed it and it was in much bigger
consequences in an online game so it wasn't that
big a deal as a blitz game but i remember being
like what in the world oh that's sick so i've
kept that in mind since then knight g6 is a great
choice by levy they're just hitting the queen and
the bishop and you're forcing off one of the pair
of bishops so it looks like it's a good trade
yeah the bishops get significantly weaker when
you divide them in half uh two bishops down to
one is a big deal actually that pawn is going to
move up to c5 defend the pawn on d4 and we've
been talking about this extra pawn that that
levy's had the whole game well he's still got
it and now it becomes more and more meaningful
well now it's on d3 it's this dark square
bishop light square on d3 rook d8 coming
and hard to see how you pile up pressure you can
play rook d2 but then the knight comes into e4
he starts with bishop e3 he wants to play bishop
d4 cutting off the queen and the pawn but then
black has the c5 move to say get your bishop out
of here that pawn is staying on the board yeah and
keep in mind that bishop might take that pawn
on a7 if you've seen it before robert i'm just
gonna be calling out uh those apons from now on
that'll be my wait wait wait can we can we take it
oh my goodness no no we please no this
can't actually happen wait but can we okay
now i'm actually a little serious that pawn
is under attack can we just steal that pawn
okay he's not it's too much yeah it's too
much but now he is threatening to take
that pawn with his queen and he cut off the
queen from the d3 pawn so if you trade on d4
i just take back and then i will win the d3 pawn
next move so this is a really good move by eric
although bishop takes a7 hats begs the question
is that pawn really hanging it does that time
is even queen d4 played there's always an idea
to just move that queen but let's say queen f5
then we're dead serious queen takes a7 has to
happen um if we trade that bishop takes back i
think it is you know reasonable to play something
like e6 keep in mind that if you just grab that
pawn on d3 there is going to be c5 that's going to
be a pin from the rook on d8 to the rook on d3 so
white can't is or is not threatening rook
takes d3 in the current position he could
have captured with the pawn on d4 which would
have allowed him to capture the pawn on d3 next
but that would be something in a capablanca game
where black just crushes because it's a terrible
bishop on the dark squares and an isolated pawn so
that's why eric took with the bishop and he's up
time levy down to 45 seconds he is better here
that's for sure he's up a pawn and as you said
c5 will be the response that we're taking d3 but
he doesn't have time so he needs to move quickly
yeah bishop d4 and b6 is natural are we gonna
see b4 to sort of counteract that c5 move or
are we gonna are we gonna maybe see f3 uh king
out basically rosen is trying to take that pawn
in the best way possible he he wants to take it
and have an even structure he plays the move f3
he can't have everything though robert um he
has to focus on winning that pawn back at all
yeah the reason why i didn't like b4 for white
is i don't want to even think about that black
pawn game c4 to protect the past pawn so if he
keeps the pawn on b3 even if you get c5 you're
not getting c4 in so right now in knight hi i
like that move and rook takes d3 there's still
c5 walking into a pin don't do that so king f2
makes sense but now that knight can come into f4
yeah knight f4 and i mean the bishop is going to
be attacked by some sort of knight e6 and still
rook takes d3 not possible g5 played and are we
going to see like rook e1 uh b4 all these moves
come to mind i think it's still a very tense game
levy is actually the one getting low on time here
he is 22 seconds and rookie one there could be
a rookie seven out of nowhere and the bishop on
d4 is staring at the g7 pawn so you have to watch
out for that and rookie one also there's a rookie
five move hitting the g5 pawn so rookie one played
20 seconds not for levy you got to go did you play
g4 here no he says let's go to c5 and i played
e5 well e3 was also good but that knight has
nowhere to go i'll take it pretty much wherever
it uh runs to yeah uh i guess in this position i
would probably look the stick of rook on e8 um to
challenge that uh that e file now c4 happens and
rook d5 just looks silly it goes back to d7 rookie
3 rook fd8 at least you're holding on that pawn
but the problem is your knight can't get back in
i will take your knight and blockade your pawn so
i actually think that white has very good chance
to hold i would probably start with rook d2 here
i don't even want to think about your pawn pushing
but if your pawn does push i guess i can actually
team up on it more easily so he does play g4 he
probably will take this knight no matter where it
goes but seven seconds eight seconds okay he moved
and rook e5 without using a rookie four instead
it's almost like a bullet move where you get
them pre-moving g5 or something because ricky
[ __ ] doesn't look as good no and now i would
play king e2 probably and just go near the pawn
h4 all right making sure that black can't push the
pawns now king e2 but there's always rook c3 keep
in mind like rick c1 threat and he can't take d2
without losing f3 oh rook takes f4 that's a pawn
i'll grab that one or take that f4 maybe rook e8
to follow then rookie four right i just try to
trade off some rooks and get my king d2 but a4
that's nice you're trying to break down white's
pawn structure but if a b rook takes rook takes d2
he gets the pass pawn and now it's even material
yeah and 1.6 seconds for levy i mean is someone
going to flag this game it really feels like it
oh i got 1.8 he barely got that move up three
seconds for eric he plays hr that's a good move
pawn chain rook five another group of keep your
pieces defended now the seventh rank is scary
pawn goes down rook b7 rook d7 to follow rook d6
here probably wins g6 i think that's king this
king can come into the position king f6 kg5
king f4 careful of that king oh my gosh king
takes g4 whose past pawn is better i don't know
don't play rook g3 g6 is hanging rookie two's
almost mate though yeah it's almost majority
players rook d2 and rookie are going for a game
0.4 seconds how is that even possible oh they
go with 0.1 seconds barely is possible i wasn't
gonna fight you and now levy's up a point that's
me we'll get one's mate oh my goodness oh my gosh
someone was gonna lose that game eric is so
he just didn't react and levy just like what
just happened this is ridiculous and it's an even
match and white still has not even scored a half
point it is six nothing for the players the black
pieces in a 3-3 match overall that makes no sense
when white makes the first move every engine that
you could ever see in the world is going to say
yeah white has a slight advantage after e4 and yet
we've seen no wins with the white pieces this is
crazy uh somehow right now you know black is just
cracked i mean they know something that we don't
robert because uh some of them about the opening
choices in this match uh i mean it's almost like
you get the black pieces and you're feeling more
confident and i'm just looking at the players
levy kind of looks like he's struggling for breath
after what was a crazy finish and eric's looking
like he's making decisions at the grocery store
he just doesn't react like he's just there hanging
out like does he not feel the pain of just losing
that game by getting checkmated in a two-rook
position i am just out of words and eric is just
calmly biting into his hoodie and moving on i
think that's about as nervous as you'll see him
get you know the classic you know yellow hoodie
collar bite is uh that's the most emotion you'll
you'll get out of uh eric rosen as again you
pointed it out he's already just focused on this
next match whereas levy it's like you can almost
see the the the cold war flashbacks from last game
in his eyes and for eric you should be happy he's
got the black piece in this game but actually i
like white's position because of this [ __ ] don't
say that robert i i you know i tend to think that
white has good chances here but after this 94 move
it's funny that's the tempting move but i think
white should have probably started with c5 because
look at the knight coming right back to d2
that's saying f5 could have come now at least
i'm attacking the pawn on e5 so f5 doesn't work
but black can probably play in bishop d6 or queen
d6 or something to defend the pawn he does play
bishop d6 and the setup is solid white is still
trying to play c5 and advance the knight but
that d3 pawn that's always a potential weakness
yes this classic position so you give up the
bishop pair two bishops for black but by doing
that then they don't have six it's so instrumental
in controlling the center especially the light
squares e4 and d5 you give that up well now look
knight e4 the other knight maybe can cycle back to
d2 we might see the c pawn push followed by knight
d2 to c4 and all of a sudden every piece for white
is getting involved here robert that's true and
then c6 it's it's supposed to be a good piece it's
developed but often you want the knight on d7 to
go into like c5 and try to make progress there and
right now knight after d2 you called it the
bishop on g2 watch out on that diagonal there
could be some problems here and c5 for white
and then knight to c4 and all of a sudden those
knights are getting into the game the bishop is
thriving on the long diagonal and black is in
some trouble there trying to defend the position
and bishop g6 i was about to say f5 such a big
idea in this position and you know a well-timed
e4 for black is usually what makes it break this
position for either side g4 you might look at that
move and say you know what the heck is levy up to
but this is a positional idea taking control of
f5 and we actually might see this knight on d2
uh either reroute f1 to g3 or maybe the knight on
e4 dropping back to g3 it's all about controlling
the light squares which is why levy gave up his
dark square bishop for a knight and the main
drawback of course is the dark squares there so if
you move that knight away from d2 i will consider
playing bishop takes e4 and then bishop g5 very
quickly get my bishop into f4 cause your king
you know some problems over there and c5 is a good
move it takes up space that knight can go into the
c4 square maybe into b6 or d6 so levy has things
going on for him but i would even consider rook a5
saying are you are you gonna get away with knight
to c4 maybe that c5 pawn is a target i guess it
might not work out in that immediate position
but rook a5 that rook lift is actually thematic
yeah it's either going to be rook a5 or rook
c8 but brook a5 makes more sense because you
don't want to just drop the a4 pawn now that you
put it there you can't just drop it for nothing
king h8 speaks to the fact that rosen might be
feeling like hey white's doing all the you know
has all the ideas here i have to do something king
h8 says you know at some point the move f5 makes
some sense now i want to get off this diagonal
and he takes an e4 because he says the c5 pawn
is no longer defended the g5 square i can bring my
bishop there or if i take on c5 first my queen can
get out over to g5 or h4 the problem with this is
there are going to be times where bishop takes c6
knight takes e5 tactically work out for what this
is uh i think it seems very uh fortunate that it
is working out because after bc6 knight takes
e5 rook is threatening the c5 bishop and hang on
that king on h8 does not look very smart right now
because knight takes e5 also now threatens knight
takes f7 so you have the move queen d5 and that
queen is a hero protecting literally everything
the c5 bishop the c6 pawn and the f7 square while
attacking the knight on e5 so you have that saving
grace but you're right iman that you wish that
you could put that king just hey no one's looking
king's back to jail if you're playing the hustlers
in the park you there quickly put the king back
into g8 and then make a different move and here
queen definitely only option and isn't this very
tricky queen d5 knight takes f7 king g8 looks like
a really fun move to play because you almost say
look that knight on f7 stranded after king g8
it's like wait a minute i thought i was the one
with the white pieces doing the tactic could we
see this flip around right away knight f7 looks
like a very reasonable move to play yeah what a
shocking move king g8 would be and the thing about
this position is even if i had to take your knight
and go down a pawn you wish that pawn speaking of
sliding pieces could that pawn go back maybe one
square or two back to g3 or g2 because your king
is going to be open for the rest of the game but
that is an amazing thing to see iman with knight
f7 king g8 and your knight has nowhere to go yeah
it's such a funny move and i think maybe levy's
starting to realize that now because you almost go
into this thinking okay the guys king's on h8 with
the rook pressuring c5 i simply have knight takes
f7 winning upon queen you know has to take rook
takes c5 but knight f7 king g8 and suddenly it's
your knight who's getting trapped and we could
see black win yet another game in this series and
the thing is if you move your knight back casually
like knight c4 black says i'm gonna get rid of my
back rank problems with an attack with h5 ripping
your king side open and then my bishop later can
come to the bh2 diagonal my queen's coming over to
the king side to cause some threats i don't like
white's position all of a sudden it felt like
there was something there and then you go for the
direct win of material and it backfires because
of this wonderful king j8 move that we've been
pointing out so this is a scary position for levy
yeah and there's not an easy decision to make
here because knight c4 as you mentioned there's
there's moves like h5 coming up the the fact
is the queen can't get out and after knight f3
rook takes e1 as the first move that comes to mind
because you cannot play well doesn't look like you
should play queen takes e1 uh dropping the knight
and dropping a whole bunch of puns near your king
that would probably not be ideal and i'm still
looking at this h5 move just to give my king
some space off the back rank he does take on e1
first that looks good and brookdale how could
you blame him for developing his pieces and his
attack he does luce said the a4 pawn so there i
wouldn't take that right now that's going
away from the king that looks scary with
queen g5 coming things like that but that
pawn a4 at some point can be captured so levy
how does periphery he's going to be looking at
that definitely and the reason you want to loosen
up this wow he took it excuse me is this a match
of taking random a pawns it looks like it robert
queen takes a4 and i mean this just looks too
greedy to me but hey uh queen g5 that's the
first thing that comes to mind it hits the
c1 rook and it hits the g4 pawn with chat
look bishop d6 also is tricky because if you
play queen takes c6 then that rook takes e1 shack
distracting your rook from the queen's protection
and when the queen recaptures you cover the back
rank so that tactic would uh be good so yeah
that wouldn't work out for white there's this
trick and the rook's overloaded yeah and the queen
watching e8 is actually so important in that line
so you really have to notice that to go for it
but it does work out perfectly for block yeah
i think bishop d6 is the way to go because
you're staring right at that white king side
and it looks like you can mount a serious attack
so i don't even know what the best response is to
bishop d6 because your move queen g5 comes next
and he plays bishop b6 step one complete queen g5
step two checkmate inevitably step three that's a
scary three-step process just that outline for our
viewers here robert um bishop d6 i mean you've
pointed everything out it's it's queen e5 it's
queen g5 it's the fact that h5 gets rid of back
rank for black and continues the attack um this
looks really difficult to meet because that knight
all you want to do is put it on f3 and play king
g2 all at once but you can't do either of those
moves at the moment and you'll never do both of
them together no you will not and just coming up
with a move is difficult for white if you play
queen back to d1 yeah you keep your king side
safer for now but i still make a move like h5
or rookie 6 rook lift and queen g5 is possible
right now because you want queen to c4 so i'm
going to play queen g5 and just attack the g4 pawn
keep an eye on your rook on c1 what do you do here
do you like play h3 but then c5 how's queen
takes c6 i mean are we getting completely mated
here like i know queen takes g4 is like completely
ridiculous but at the same time white just had to
make a move and with 18.7 seconds i think queen
c6 is reasonable yeah it is and after king h1
you can just play d8 maybe and keep the attack
alive because that bishop on d6 is staring at
the king and there's no queen takes d6 which is
important there would be background checkmates
but the queen on g4 covers that c8 square so you
are safe for the moment and there's gonna have to
be an investment by black after defending the
rook and taking care of these pieces which are
forked by the way uh there just is gonna have to
be an h5 or a g6 move uh because back rank threats
throughout this entire end game it's just not
possible to deal with everything and queen h3
is a pretty big threat hitting h2 throwing the f1
square that's why he drops the queen back to f3
and just bring your queen back somewhere i'm not
sure where yeah not gonna be a trade here no sir
queen g5 maybe just uh hey maybe you don't notice
your rook's hanging you have 4.9 seconds yeah yeah
h6 for black just like give my king some safety
maybe even uh at some point h5 because it controls
g4 but yeah we just need upon we need something
in front of the king i would say queen g5 okay
there's that threat to the rook five he barely got
the move off oh my gosh queen it should check this
king f1 what a way to weasel out of this for levy
yes because he's playing on the light squares now
every piece is safe king f1 you can quickly
oh he walked right into it and he had no time
and he shakes his head gets up and bounces and
eric's like all right it's it's chill we're
still just playing eric's just pouring another
cup of tea i mean it's just a day in the office
this is such an intense match eric rosen takes
the lead at the end of the five minute portion
oh what was needed there was just like king
f1 or something it just those those two
seconds you're never going to play perfect
chess all the time amman seven games played
seven wins for the player with the black
pieces what in the world is going on
i think everybody in this match needs to go and
check their repertoire and make sure they actually
had some openings prepared as white because it
looks like everybody's just winging it right now
and everyone prepared with the black pieces or
something because let's be let's be clear these
guys are playing great but uh we're not seeing any
big advantages and especially not any conversions
with the white pieces no the the biggest lead's
been one it's been a win for one player win for
the other it's a strike back immediately so this
is as even of a match as it gets eric gets to go
into the break with the lead and before we take
our break i just want to ask your iman and what's
the mindset like for them because it is really a
50 50 shot except for a you know win there in the
final position on time and getting checkmated well
i i think what we've seen from this match is that
uh these guys are allergic to uh draws let's
put it that way um if there's a time scramble
and it's even time we don't see players offering
draws we see absolute chaos on the board you and i
losing our minds our voices uh it it's basically
indicating that every game seems to finish with
a decisive result so time scramble skills are
super super important in this match and coming
back into it you just want to regroup and remember
in the three minute portion if you're getting in
that time pressure it's going to be even worse so
that's something to think about yeah it's a good
thing to leave our viewers with we'll bid you
adieu just for now we'll be back in a few and
when we return we'll have more of this levy versus
eric speeches championship match brought to you by
chess.com
and just a reminder of our 16
participants in the upcoming pogchamps 3
it's going to be a great tournament
filled with your favorite streamers
celebrities poker stars and more
amman i know i'm looking for it starts
just in a few days from now yeah and it's
going to be an exciting one robert if you've
you know been tuned into the chess category you've
probably noticed quite a number of these players
um getting some coaching and getting tuned up for
the event which is exactly what we like to see
the players are taking that as seriously as the
players are taking today's match by the looks of
it robert so if uh today's match was a taste of
adrenaline in chess that you haven't experienced
before uh we got that event coming right up we
certainly do and i am just pumped to see how
this match keeps going here because seven games
seven wins for the black pieces both sides have
had their chances time scrambles have been a thing
and it feels like for levy better clock management
is a necessity at this point in three-minute chess
you can't afford to spend two minutes early like
he did in some of the five-minute games but
then again he was playing really good chess
so it's hard to fault him completely there i don't
know what the right solution is yeah it's so hard
to say i always say live and die by the sword but
uh we're into this next match i think at the very
least levy is gonna see three minutes on the clock
and realize that that's a more comfortable more
natural time control that's the arena kings format
the title tuesday when he's playing blitz on
stream that's probably going to be more familiar
territory for him and i think that that could
you know make him feel more comfortable yeah and
for eric in some of these time scrambles levy has
gotten the upper hand so he needs to be careful
about that and as you said title tuesday has this
time control and levy's beaten even peter spidler
one of the very best players in the world so we
know that he has what it takes to win games in
this format and right now we have another caracon
that b5 has just been played that is an aggressive
move that can often backfire if white can time an
a4 push at some moment so that's a dangerous
move to play if you're levy especially having
not canceled yet and it looks like a strange move
to play against someone who's got a knight on c2
because it controls the b4 square so nicely and it
it's full queen side development over here bishop
to b7 uh is he playing a castle queen side it
looks insane with moves like a4 so i'm questioning
that bishop on b7 is it ever going to get open i'm
looking at moves like queen e2 bishop g5 and just
planting knight in on e5 yeah that's thematic here
and if your king finds it doesn't just drop a pawn
um so knight takes e5 and then pawn takes bishop
takes e5 does he did he hallucinate some sort of
queen e2 bishop pig's e5 thing like there's
no there's no way this is just a free pun
yeah that caught me off guard because you were
saying queen e2 and then 95 right exactly and
then he went 95 and i'm like that doesn't look
right because he played that too fast and levy's
sitting here and calculating is there something
that we're missing down the line here i'm trying
to look at the player cams for a reaction um
and basically rosen is probably like oh my god
if i move my eyes a single bit he's gonna notice
the pawn hanging yeah he's doing secret service
we have a problem on the e5 square nobody move a
muscle and yeah levy takes it and he is now up a
pawn down 30 seconds but upon him i think that's a
good response by eric if you are going to blunder
upon the center at least complicate matters
playing a4 now if you take on a4 the rook can
capture it over there and the a6 pawn becomes a
target so the extra pawn hasn't quite made its
presence felt and well actually levy gives
the pawn right back yeah you know i tend to
agree with you robert the extra pun hasn't made
his presence felt because it's no longer there
and after a takes b5 technically you can win that
pawn back i still think black has the edge and of
course that was definitely not a good sequence
by eric to give it up in the first place but
i guess you gotta take it back even the stakes and
say you know whatever the position is that i have
now i just have to deal with it because getting
that pawn back is is worth more than anything
very interesting to not take on a4 and allow
white to take on b5 giving the pawn back
but as you were just saying black's position is
better look at this activity the knight on e4
the bishop e5 and don't sleep on that bishop on a8
because if that diagonal opens up there could be
big trouble by the way bishop h2 check forces the
king to f1 if you go to h1 you get not just forked
but checkmated so levy first plays pawn to f5
solidifies the defense that knight on e4 he would
like to take with the f pawn open up that rook
and eric will not be capturing that's for sure
no and i'll just show the people that check me
because it is it is pretty uh pretty funny the
idea just getting made it's so satisfying to do
with the knight basically a smothered mate um so
keep in mind it looks like it you know maybe just
a silly tactic you know robert's just having his
fantasies about smothered mates but no it's really
important to uh focus on those tactics see them
even when they aren't forcing and they don't
work because later on in this game we might see
that type of idea play into the game that for sure
could be the case and queen b6 puts pressure on d4
says bishop e3 don't think so queen takes b2 so
levy has really liked these queen b6 maneuvers
throughout the day and it also protects
the e6 pawn so that queen's doing it all
absolutely the only piece left to maybe improve
if you're looking at black's position just a few
small moves that he wants to play maybe bishop b7
just to get off the back rank so that the rook can
always use the a file if necessary also one step
closer to bishop ca if you need just more scope
and maybe just a move like h6 there's always time
for small moves like that so i'm i'm liking levy's
position as uh wow bishop takes e4 that is quite
a committal decision yeah that is a huge decision
and the one good thing for eric there are not many
in this position is that the pawn on b2 even if
your bishop moves the e6 pawn is also an attack
but i like the way levi recaptured because that
bishop is going to go to d5 and so even though you
didn't capture on the f-pawn to open up the rook
your bishop is more flexible and free so levi's
got a nice advantage here yeah absolutely bishop
e3 is the move you want to play so desperately
with the with the white pieces queen takes c3
knight takes e6 i don't know what the uh queen
is b2 rather knight takes e6 i don't know what
the evaluation is after that looks like he wants
to defend it and then go for bishop e3 and the
biggest difference between taking the d and the
f pawn is black and also f4 if that bishop goes
to e3 and then maybe e3 or f3 are both ripping
open that king side and so i think that levy's
in a great position to even play f4 himself say
hey is that really a bishop on c1 what you doing
over there you can't get out and i am going to try
to push my pawns and attack your king but look at
the time 45 seconds for black 35 seconds for white
we're getting into a bit of a scramble territory
and that's when mistakes happen but black really
has a nice position at this point yeah and i was
gonna say he's either thinking about rook takes
e4 or he's thinking about something crazy and
i think it was crazy knight f3 saying look if
you take me rook takes e5 what's even happening
there after f takes g2 yeah have that pawn i'll
use it as a shield that's an umbrella and that
way your bishop on eight looks great but you're
not figuring a way to attack so he doesn't take
now knight g5 is possible rookie for also
possible i was just trying to save the material
and he goes for your line because the light
squares are now under white's control and the f4
i'm a bad influence i don't know if that was the
best but it's just such a bullet instinct he saw
those 20 seconds ticking down now his position hey
it might not be the best but it's very playable
he's got two connected outside pass pawns and he
has control over some light squares be careful of
that epon getting to e5 and getting to e4 before
he can establish the blockade he does have knight
g5 now but you have to think is there f3 coming
open up that bishop e4 check things get really
crazy at this point so knight g5 there probably is
that f3 move so he goes knight to d2 and now after
f3 maybe he can go queen e4 and say wait a second
if the queen's trade well he takes it that can't
be good that completely shocked me i thought i was
gonna play queen e4 and try to trade queens and if
the queens came off my point was that hey those
past pawns in the queen side could be worth the
exchange down maybe queen g5 and then take f3 you
can't play knight takes oh that's that's for oh he
takes and does the bishop hanging yep that'll be
game all right so it's an extra rook for just two
pawns and you need to prove it you're 12 seconds
you're up on time you can do this i would make
space for my king at some point i would play h6
and just you know deal with everything else later
um eric is going to play this because hey he's
got two pawns over there but that queen trade i
think is going to cement things yeah that's
not going to help your cause here rookie 8
the knights know we're good to go the c3 pawns
hang ruxia obviously is also good and it looks
like levy for the eighth time in this match with
the black pieces the player is going to win so
i guess we're just coming to expect that black
is going to win every single game in this match
and i know there's there's not much commentary
to give at the end but i just want to say
playing rook a8 there with the rook
just a really good habit to get into
you toss your rook super far away from your king
so that it won't get forked yeah that's a good
call and there's a fork here but rook c4 you
guys would protect the bishop that's good news
and eric is the type player to play out by the
way three seconds for each player so there could
be a flag and now rook c3 knight g4 if you take
on f3 king g2 and you oh you can't get through
oh my gosh i knew it that's so funny eric finds
all of these stalemates he did it last year
against elizabeth pitts and he managed to actually
get a stalemate in one game but levy's too
aware of what's going on he's got some
free moves now and he's like all right
enough of this enough just take the
knife wait oh it's not stalemate
see that's what that's what rosa does to you
he sits there in his yellow hoodie and he makes
you think that every position on the board is
stalemate oh my gosh amman the way this match
is going wouldn't be surprised if we get to
tie breakers and if we get to armageddon i
know which color the players are going to choose
it is certainly going to be the black pieces
would be insane if black won every game in the
match and then won the tiebreaker and you know
the players just went home and that was the result
i wonder if this is getting to their heads because
obviously we're making jokes about it but do you
think they're looking at their opening repertoire
and even in this game levy sacrificed the pawn and
if eric can counter the initial pressure he should
have a good position because he's a pawn up so
another game another kind of weird opening choice
and if he can deal with the immediate danger
black will once again have the advantage
robert i i mean i have to just go back and show
that stalemate what could have happened because
that's so classic rook g3 king h1 and honestly i
might have pre-moved this in a game yes like it's
so easy to do you're like okay rook g3 i finally
won his knight that tricky guy's been forking
me everywhere rook takes g4 and you know it's
actually really really good of levy to notice that
absolutely and good awareness by both and for
levy not pre-moving knowing when and when not
supreme was a very important skill set in these
speed chess championship matches and right now
levy played the crazy opening he's the one who
sacrificed a pawn then he spent what 40 seconds on
that decision here so being upon down and spending
the clock that feels like it's not a good sign
for levy right now just castle king said of him
eric you mean the white king's in the center
white king's in the center it's a couple moves
away from uh castling and knight back to c3
it's still a few moves away from castling what
is usually called for robert when stuff like
this happens maybe move like b5 b4 just something
very ultra aggressive attack that knight dislodge
it again go after that pawn i love b5 b4 because
it almost prepares if a guy goes knight f3
you have bishop b5 after b4 you're looking
to cut that king and stop it from castling
that looks like a phenomenal sequence eric does
play b5 and he is up half a minute on the clock
this is at this point standard time controls and
knight f3 we're gonna see b4 and after 92 we will
see very likely bishop b5 and the d5 pawn is weak
this is looking really nice for black once again
knight f4 maybe can be played there might be a
knight d5 in that position i'm not too sure i'm
looking at knight g5 knight takes f4 and knight
g2 but the problem with knight d5 is you can just
take back on d5 because your bishop that yeah i'm
sorry to ruin your fun that was a nice checkmating
sequence but i don't think it's gonna happen yeah
well that i will take that off the table for now
but i still think with that bishop on b5 there's
no king side castling it might even be queen d2
and queen side castling just forced because you
gotta get your king out of the center somehow
yeah and even there it doesn't look very safe for
the king and black's king on the other hand looks
very very safe and so what's the move right now
he plays bishop c4 just going for the pawn on d5
and that if b3 can he take on d5 i guess he can
takes on d5 bishop takes f6 and then even just
bishop takes back on f6 hitting the rook on a1
which would be the case after b3 i think he might
have just missed that bishop takes d5 bishop f6
you look like you're undermining the bishop on
d5 but bishop takes back is so strong and eric's
thinking here trying to figure out if it works
out for him it does but that may mean that he
must put his bishop back and say now you're
not casting kingside still right and castling
queenside is even more dangerous because of your
pawn structure and all those weak dark
squares very reasonable to play bishop b5 but
i think at the end of the day when you see a pawn
in the center of the board and you calculate that
you can take it you almost gotta do it yeah so he
takes it and it's about even on the clock an extra
five plus seconds now for eric and the problem
for levy is not the time it's the position he is
down upon i would just castle and i'm down upon
i know it but at least i'm moving quickly i have
some clearer plans queenie two rook d1 rookie
one just make moves that are natural here and
black's extra pawn is upon e7 not exactly in the
game just yet yeah there's i mean you know down
upon in a blitz game is not going to be the worst
thing uh we've seen uh him almost get a stalemate
down an entire rook in a pawn so hey we'll
we'll take down a pawn here if you're levy uh
maybe queen e2 i feel like avoiding a queen trade
is what you want to do queen e2 followed by rookie
1 and rook d1 as you said uh bishop b5 once again
it rears its nasty head here trying to skewer the
queen on e2 and the rook on f1 and weirdly white's
pieces are just in this strange order like the
knight should be on e5 but the bishop's there and
you know the queen's on e2 and that looks fine but
bishop b5 is coming i think this should be five
anyway right now there's no good square for that
queen you go to the d-file well hello there's
rook d8 you go to e3 there might be knight g4
yeah that looks good he starts with rook to d8 and
oh bishop b5 is a very real threat so c4 i would
take that thing on passant probably but then the
bishop can capture back and maybe the queen will
go to b2 later and that's the kind of play you
need if you're levy when you're down in a pawn
i agree yeah that that looks good especially
because it it might be backed up by a queen
to b2 like if bishop b5 queen b2 all of a sudden
you're putting a lot of pressure on that bishop
on g7 and pinning the knight let's not forget it
looks a little risky right now but keep an eye
on that e7 pawn it's loose and if you ever play e6
as black that queen b2 move makes a lot more sense
yeah and the bishop on c3 is not defended so you
always want to look if the piece goes out the way
is knight h5 a move here if you take my bishop on
g7 i take your knight on f4 with tempo that kind
of tactical sequence could have been nice for eric
right there but queen b7 is such a natural move
lining your queen and bishop on the diagonal we're
looking to play bishop takes f3 and knight g5
played so hang on a sec after h6 which is like the
natural move is there some sort of knight e6 or
knight takes f7 what's going on that probably was
the plan and that's why eric would rook to d7s and
all right if you go 96 i'll have to figure it out
now he does it but now these 96 knight takes g6
all these tactics are flying i guess eric's just
going to take the piece and they have to fly right
now though otherwise they won't work at all that
night he's got to make a decision and i think with
time taking down you sort of err on the side of
caution like i don't want to throw this game away
with a ridiculous sack unfortunately the caution
often is bad for the side that sound material
because it makes it black's life easier here and
now you're up a pawn e5 is coming he plays it the
g2 pawn is hanging if the knight moves out the
way oh no where can i not even go to knight d3
but then bishop b5 is possible there too so this
looks like it's dropping material there's no
way this works um g2 still falls plus you're in a
completely nasty pin and knight g4 right to d7 is
going to win the game okay so where's the material
he takes there is there queen f3 nice move bishop
bishop f6 queen g4 check and take on h4 if the
rook goes to g3 steal some material he goes queen
of five hitting out of the pin credit to rosen and
levy for the the sequences okay queen g4 check and
the e5 is hanging so he takes just right away okay
you didn't even need to move the queen and what's
the finish here what's that's a tricky move queen
f4 okay let's look at some time yeah two seconds a
piece i'm trying to figure it out quick before
check one second and barely get the giveaway
and now black is up oh rookie five at some point
is dangerous okay for a levy he's he's moving the
queen but there's just no good moves rook g5's
winning winning the game yeah that queen is now
hanging and that's one of those situations
move the piece out of the way and then you
get discovery black wins for the night time in a
row it is about to be an adoption with the black
pieces this i i swear to god robert everything
i know about chess has told me that white is
supposed to have an advantage like there's a
reason that when you have a chess match like
the world championship you have an even number
of games so that one player doesn't get the extra
well now i know the extra black pieces would be
having an advantage right so it's not you know
i'm not wanting that extra white piece i don't
want to move first i want to respond because then
i have a psychological edge and we get back to
this keracon and look queenie two this time oman
he understood that 95 was two c he needs the rook
as well he can't forget the rook this time there
we go there it is there it is all the pieces lined
up in the e5 square and i like these positions for
white because it's kind of like a london system in
a way that bishop on d3s hits across the position
to the h7 pawn so if you castle king side 95
happens bishop g5 your king could quickly come
under fire because most of black's pieces are
over there on the queen side the problem right
with casting queenside though is that a4 your
pawn is too advanced on b5 there so knight to d7
and weird move to play i was actually wondering
what you thought of maybe the move knight e4
and uh giving up a pawn and playing 95 and just
kind of opening up those bishops and saying hey
that's a that's a way to play you know look for a
castle and a very aggressive setup knight d7 much
more passive it is much more passive and you're
also moving another piece away from your king side
so if you castle that way you're probably walking
into a checkmate attack and look at this knight g5
threatening the h7 pawn sacrifice on e6 or f7
so knight f8 played but can't white just play
a move like knight e3 threatening the d5 pawn
bringing the knight to f5 perhaps pins galore
problems with that black king in the center i
think that this could be a pretty swift game but
it's the white pieces so no this game yeah of
course not what are we talking about blacks
looks much better here ignore that evaluation bar
um i was going to say even taking on b4 moving
that dark square bishop and just getting rook c1
it's like the knight on f8 sure it covers things
but you can't castle now and queen h5 makes yet
another threat knight takes e6 is in the position
robert utilizing that new pin wow and where does
black even go here g6 the queen just goes right
up to h6 doesn't mind hanging out on the g7 square
because that rook will get trapped in the corner
so this looks really unpleasant for levy right now
i don't see a way to do it make queen d7 just like
protect e6 right now and say all right there's
no knockout blow i can hold on maybe i will
get to castle eventually just i don't know when
eventually happens yeah and it will be that g6
move queen h6 to g7 is the threat and so rook g8
just to stop it but without even being up a pawn
here just look at the evaluation bar it's you know
cresting the two plus two plus three almost and i
mean it's because you just look at the position
and it's clear to see black's pieces are doing
nothing they're reacting to white's threats and
there's so many good things for white to do here
and castling queenside doesn't actually shield
your king you're walking into another attack it's
a different attack but it's still a very strong
attack and actually white can consider taking on
h7 right now just grabbing that pawn and then the
black king would have to castle queen side after
a trait of knight so instead eric plays the calm
move surprising that eric rosen plays a calm move
bishop to d2 just hitting the b4 pawn a third
time yeah and really looking to say look uh long
castle c4 right i'm going to open everything
up there is no side of the board that's safe
for you the king side not safe the middle well
doesn't look very safe and now that he's played
this we might see a very very quick rook c1 c4
and just busting the entire position wide open
and that kind of restraint shows that he's a very
strong player because you could have taken on h7
but the material is less important to him than
just dominating the board and not giving levy
any chances whatsoever sometimes you take pieces
give up more squares your opponent look at this
move knight g4 coming into f6 your rook is going
to get trapped your knight on f8 is stuck the f7
pawn is under attack so if you played bishop
e7 thank you for the f7 pawn don't mind if i
capture that i don't really see moves for black
that look the least bit appealing and f4 is there
and knight takes e6 there's like okay maybe it's
taking queens but there's 96 at the very least
yeah bishop f4 is one of those moves
that's like you know it might hold for
the second but i feel like i can even take and
play pawn g3 and just kick your queen away and
go knight f6 eventually and now you're in big
trouble yeah at this point i mean look at black
species they're they're just doing nothing but
let's not forget levy is staying in the game i
mean i'm super impressed the way rosen is handling
this you know very mature he's taking his time
he's not cashing in material advantage but the
longer you wait to cash in an advantage there's
always a chance that you maybe miss a move and all
of a sudden it's not there for you to take anymore
yeah that check could pass its expiration date
and there could be a time where black has like
knight a5 and closes down the queen side protects
the pawn of b3 stops c4 all at once and c4 now
that you played f6 looks even more powerful
because that e6 pawn is now weaker because
the pawn f7 no longer defends his friend and
there's c4 bishop takes c4 will hit e6 hit b3
the position is really opening up and levy's
king is the one that's not safe the king on g1
is well that's very happy to be there and maybe
oh it doesn't look good but maybe knight b4
um if you take it at least i take with the
bishop and make a threat on your rook and then
maybe taking dc4 in the future is not so bad that
bishop on v7 opens up against the knight on f3
that's a good call knight b4 is pretty interesting
he does play it here and the bishop is hanging so
you have to react in some manner you can't take on
d5 you just drop the bishop that wouldn't be good
and by the way that bullet territory 40 seconds
for white 34 for black this is where the mistakes
really happen and it's getting tactical if you
look bishop f1 is knight c2 happening with a four
that looks kind of worrisome and he takes their
place rookie two that seems to be a good call
yeah but why don't we maybe just take the pawn
on c4 and go king b8 uh it doesn't look like the
best but that bishop opening up in the knight
on f3 you could even take that and take on d4
yeah that's actually a good call and then you just
remove your bishop from b7 saying i don't care
about my king's defense let me rip your king open
but now that bishop is a terrible french bishop
it's stuck behind a wall of pawns the e6 pawn is
still weak 15 seconds counting down for levi he
doesn't even have a good looking move if you go 97
rookie one the e6 pawn is weak what do you do here
bishop c8 maybe just to add support to e6 bishop
c6 dropping the a pawn yeah that's an important
one because you take on a6 go right back to b5 and
then you go for the attack yeah and he he missed
that queen a7 maybe looking for a cheapo with
bishop d5 tape that would be that'd be pretty
funny and here once again one second oh my gosh
he gets the move off and where is the finishing
touch queen e3 looks good take that pawn on b3
and that should be a second extra pawn and the
king's in trouble yep and he takes that bishop a5
and he's gonna grab the bishop because you take
the queen takes b8 remember the knight on f8 the
rooks are not connected no that's a problem 1.3
seconds left so bishop takes c6 he doesn't do it
and now all of a sudden levy's trying to escape
but his next bishop's trapped oh my goodness look
at it it's like he's playing against horde chess
yeah oh tbc the queen drops the queen drops oh
and that's a win for eric the first victory for
the white pieces of the match and now it
is six to four our biggest lead of the day
two point spread eric rosen who goes into the
break probably pretty happy camper you couldn't
tell by looking in his face he looks the same no
matter what move is being played he could blunder
his queen or make a seven move sacrifice
for mate and he still looks like he's just
not even playing chess yeah uh i mean i think
the the wit the way the chat is going right now
the energy that you can feel from the chat i think
you and i feel it as well robert this is not only
the most hyped match but it's also delivered you
know there's a lot of matches that are hyped up
this one is delivering it is so intense it feels
like it's just one game swinging in the balance
and it just swung in eric rosen's favor it's six
to four he's opened up currently the biggest lead
of the match it's been back and forth every
single game what do you think these players are
going to be thinking about going into the break
robert as now eric has the first two game lead
if i'm levy i need to keep this spread at the
maximum because i believe levy is the favorite
come bullet time but if you go down three games
then you think do i actually have enough time
eric is of course a good bullet player so will
i have enough time to come back in the match
so it's only a two point spread both players have
had chances this was definitely levy's worst game
of the match he had no chance to get active so
eric did something very accurately here to say
levy you just can't move your pieces i'm going to
dominate the game and that's why we saw our first
victory with the white pieces because levi just
couldn't move so i think that eric did everything
right that game but this has been a very balanced
match thus far yeah i think uh robert you and i
are going to catch our breath people in the chat
you know get those spam hands ready and be back to
cheer on your favorite either levy rosman or
eric rosen when we come back after the break
so
and after our first win for a player with the
white pieces we see the match score at six to
four in eric rosen's favor mom we just had a brief
break there what do you think the players did do
you think they went to look at their openings and
work on their preparation or just say forget chess
for a few minutes i need a break well i hope that
levy took a look at that line we've been seeing
because i think it's been the most common
line in the entire match so i'm referring to
the knight a3 i think that's the easiest
way to remember it knight a3 variation
seems to be throwing him off and i am not
liking that setup i mentioned it before
that i don't like this a6 b5 bishop b7 setup
that he went for he was bailed out one game
because uh eric basically forgot and hung upon
um so that game you know worked out for him but
um i think that overall now that uh eric's
demonstrated that once he gets that knight to
e5 it's really really painful i think he needs to
be real careful and hopefully he switched that out
yeah and for a coach and content creator
known for many of his gambits and tricky lines
eric has played a very measured match i mean
throughout this one he's played his knight a3922
right you're saying this 983 line and he's playing
for a positional bind and he played a great game
in that 10th one and that's why he was able to
secure a two-game lead and for levi he is playing
really well there was that game where he ended up
checkmating eric with queen b1 checkmate which was
surprised but before all the wild stuff happened
he was out playing eric for sure so there's been
very good moments for levi that he shouldn't
forget about even though now he's down by two
points yeah and neither player uh i think
it's obvious to them but i want to remind
everybody that neither player i'm sure feels like
this match is over a two point lead not even close
levy has made up so many differences in the bullet
portion that um you know we're not even done to
three minute here robert and there's still bullet
coming up so i feel like there's still so much of
this match to happen and remember in bullet things
can move so quickly that you can make up way more
points in that section alone than sometimes
the other two combined that's can be the case
and we've seen that before and we have liftoff in
game 11 c4 played an e5 so we have a sicilian with
colors reversed and now we have this f5 line are
we going to get this knight f6 d5 pawn sacrifice
like we saw earlier and here i think so because um
well levy's going to repeat it because it worked
out for him but the thing is and here we go eric
i was going to say eric is going to remember what
the line actually is i don't think he played
it properly he played knight takes d5 last time
a little bit too hasty i believe the c6 is the
move right because if pawn takes c6 you can even
just take back with your pawn and the d3 pawn
is weak and look at this eric playing instantly
levy took a pause that's not good news for levy
because when you're met with a pawn sacrifice
and then e4 trying to take over the d3 square
with that check keeping the king in the center
that's some scary stuff it certainly is you can
tell for those wondering uh you know the answer to
robert's question hey what did the players do in
the break this is what eric rosen did in the break
it looks really good because you're planting the
knight on d3 you could take that pawn back on d5
with your pawn and once you do that pawn on e4 is
protected which means the d3 square is protected
as well so oh gosh what do you mean dude 95
i guess a necessity and that's a good move
and queen takes d5 offering the queen trade
that 995 could get caught in the center
yeah it looks like you pretty much have to
take this remember there's still knight c2 as
a follow-up afterwards to uh fork the king and the
rook castling looks like a move but hang on that
night we talked about it maybe getting stranded
out there is that something to worry about or
do you leave it out there and go for a counter
attack like bishop d2 or a3 on black's knight
you need to because bishop d6 does trap the knight
that knight is trapped in e5 you go to g4 i play
h5 and there's nowhere else to go so or you play
f4 but you don't play that happily you can even
just take on e5 play bishop e6 and then say you
have the two bishops quote-unquote advantage
how's your bishop on g2 looking right yeah at that
point white would need to reroute that bishop to
d4 a slow journey um and the pawn on e5 would be
a pass pawn but also not connected to any other
pawn on the board a potential weakness after
something as simple as knight d3 or knight c6
yeah you play knight d3 you play rook c8 you
take over the queen side over there and this
is a big moment because taking on e5 giving up
the bishop pair not easy to do and he does just
that uh no he is not yet so okay sorry i thought
he oh he does i was like in the future well no i i
actually clicked on something and all of a sudden
the moves happen and i was like wait how did that
happen i didn't see the players moving yet here
we are and predicting the future but eric just
playing good moves knight to d3 going after
the b2 pawn taking the c1 square rook c8 next
we will see bishop c3 a very very normal move here
uh the bishop is anchored supported by the b-pawn
and of course it watches over the two pawns that
the knight on d3 was attacking so bishop c3 i can
see this working out for for levy here i do think
that eric has the better position but there's
something about that bishop on c3 and d4 just so
solid defending everything in the position if the
the f-file can be used by uh levy's rooks then all
of a sudden things could crash down for for rosen
sometimes you see a a sacrifice like an exchange
stack opening things up let's say the rook for
that light square bishop on e6 followed by bishop
h3 sometimes that's the way to play with white
and a big problem that's going to be here is if
you instead of sacrificing exchange go bishop f1
black can just play bishop f5 like you could
take me on d3 we'll get opposite called bishops
but that's a passed pawn on d3 that you have
to deal with so that's what eric is relying
on here bishop f1 bishop f5 keep that knight
oh he moves it back i don't like that decision
no i i visibly was disturbed by that move like
that that knight c5 is not the right one because
after this is he going back to d3 no he's allowing
it to be traded yeah that's you're backing up and
it allows levy the time to connect his rooks
but whenever look on c1 the knight on d3 was
covering the c1 square so playing bishop f5 was
defending tonight allowing opposite color bishops
but white's excuse me black's light square
bishop would have been better and that pass
pawn was stronger for black it was more advanced
so instead we have this position i think he has to
go back to d3 now i don't like the look of knight
a4 you play palm b3 and there goes your knight
and d6 does drop that a6 pawn we've talked about
stray apons in this match that's another one and
he does go back to d3 now we've already looked at
ideas like you know if these rooks trade and white
goes for it the pawn on d3 the black rock's gonna
get activated and again i think there's some sort
of security that these guys have in the back of
their mind that hey there's opposite bishops in
this position you know it's not the worst yeah the
rooks get traded it's immediately a draw so that's
the thing that eric can count on he's down upon
but it's double pawns opposite-colored bishops
you can't push that e5 pawn to passer that can't
move so i think bishop f5 and rook c2 coming maybe
black can play for more though right if you get
a quick bishop f5 bishop e4 yourself or bishop
h3 here it's the white king that's in some big
trouble yeah and i actually like maybe something
like bishop c3 for rook d2 i feel like you need
to wrangle some control of your own second rank
and there would also be an e4 threat after that as
well that's true and i'm wondering if i can just
play bishop h3 and give up my pawn on b7 and try
to checkmate the king right if i get a quick rook
g2 check and your king has to go into the corner
there could be checkmate and it's eric's material
and he is up 20 seconds so he can think before
he just gives away this pawn b7 with check
but bishop h3 is a serious move it is because the
idea that robert's pointing out um and i'll just
even put it on the board bishop h3 let's say rook
takes b7 king e6 brook takes g7 or something rook
d2 and king f1 would be met by rook takes g3
discovered attack hitting that rook and if the
king has to go to the corner i mean here you're
already wondering hey after king h1 rook f2
is it just game over or something like that i
mean this is already something to be concerned
about for sure and that's why we did not see that
instead after the king went to c7 very smartly
levy trades the rooks and this game is a complete
draw there is no way to make progress because your
extra pawn is doubled and even if you get e4 and
trade the pawns there you can't push through to
e6 black controls that square so this seems to be
a very simple draw i would be extremely surprised
if somebody wins this game that would yeah
how could that even happen yeah the thing is
basically uh rosen doesn't even care about e4 even
though e4 technically lights up a clean clean pawn
it really doesn't matter as long as you have the
pawns somewhere where you can protect them uh this
should be a super easy draw for these guys
i'm actually surprised they're playing it on
the one thing i'd be worried about if i'm eric
is if g4 and some bishop f8 but you don't have
time because that's why eric brought his king over
to f7 to make sure those pawns are safe and it's
like you we can trade on d5 that doesn't bother me
my king gets the f5 square and you're not getting
your pawn oh whoa that's kind of point of getting
one time here two seconds point six seconds left
and then you pre-move king g6 which is a good call
i wouldn't even think i'd be being sneaky if i'm
levy you know some kind of quick quick movie a
bishop sacrifice bishop e7 here so if king of
seven's pre-moved you win the g5 pawn yeah he's
got two seconds this is uh getting a little crazy
and he's putting up on h3 which is really smart
king f7 and then pre-bishop c8 bishop v6 just
just go back and forth yeah you can put that
king on d7 um and then you pre-move this
bishop anywhere you like really and now now he's
seemingly got it under control but man that was
unnecessarily scary for a second there yeah that
was way too close to zero seconds remaining and
he does blockade the pawn and he can just
go bishop g4 bishop e6 just do not put your
bishop on a square where it can be taken
and b4 played and they agreed to a draw
okay there's always that moment where you know
it's a draw and you almost want to just repeat
moves because taking the time to go over and
click draw you might even click resign i mean
who knows that the hands are shaking with the
nerves i have done that before and that is one of
the worst feelings in the world you're like it is
it's a complete draw and then you resign and your
opponent's kind of like what is wrong with that
person i misclicked okay yeah who is this and wow
levy looks like a guy who has taken a look at
that variation robert pleased to see it and he's
taking a page out of eric's book because eric's
been playing knight day three all match levi's
like well why don't i put mine in the rim who
cares about chess principles if eric one of the
best content creators like myself is doing it and
we're both instructive coaches hey let's put those
nights on the rim baby exactly yeah we just have
to hope there's not too many people taking notes
so we might see somewhere in the 500 to 1200 elo
range a lot of nights on the rim after this match
yeah this is something where as a coach i often
say do as i say not as i do because this is
not recommended for you to put your knights on
scoring h6 but it does make sense you can bring
your knight to f5 in the near future your bishop
on g7 still is on an open diagonal but open to
what look at this poncho b2 c3 d4 your bishop
doesn't look all that strong there so i do like
eric's position out of the opening here and watch
out queen d2 if knight f5 there could be a g4
trapping that knight so be very careful if you're
levy with that knight on the rim and that's why
h3 not only are you taking away squares from uh
you know the bishop the knight on g4 but also
supporting that g4 thrust if the knight gets
the f5 and somehow you can you can simply trap
it as you mentioned so again i'm feeling these
openings are really working out for eric but f6
and knight f7 finally indicates a brand new plan
of e5 and that will require a reaction from eric
and it's a risky choice because look at those
light squares on the king side right the king on
g8 that diagonal from a2 towards that king there
could be some problems there so queen b3 comes
to mind but then levi will play e6 but he wants
to play e5 and that's why eric says i'm going
to strike immediately and look at levees he did
pawn and d5 you take me i take your bishop on b5
you take on c6 i take back and black will get the
bishop pair with a lot of open space i don't think
eric really wants that to happen so he takes on
c6 and might try to keep the position more close
i'm not i feel like i'm not a fan of this you know
it's not so bad of course there's knight c3 to
follow you can take a knight c3 that looks good
as well i was also considering maybe bishop a4
and if dc4 d5 and just play against that e pawn
in that position so i think that rosen still has
a lot of attractive options but there is an idea
to just sort of play against the d-pawn here for
white which if you can imagine an exchange between
those two pawns that is going to be an isolated
pawn robber something that we touched on in some
earlier positions although if you take on c4 push
that pawn to d5 and then you can play knight d4 at
some moment queen e2 the e7 pawn isn't happy the
e6 squares whites for the taking so i'm starting
to like the initiative that white has and that
pawn on c4 doesn't feel that relevant just yet
without now it does because he's saying i'll give
you e7 my bishop blockades your past pawn if you
take it and my pawns can start marching i really
like that decision by levy yeah and this is going
to be extremely double-edged we've got two bishops
a pass pawn for white here you could also call it
an isolated pawn depends on which side uh you're
playing with here and also b5 cementing that
c4 pawn and saying look later on b4 is c3 and
it's black who's gonna have a pass bond as well
although something thematic that white will try
for is d6 followed by knight to d5 you push your
pass bond even though it's isolated and get in
trouble as if you can get your knight to d5 behind
that pawn that's really good news for you he plays
g4 first where's that knight going has to go
back over to h6 and maybe there's even bishop c7
then pawn to d6 then knight to d5 and knight to
d4 all the white pieces seem to be cooperating
and he leads with his rook but that does allow
levy to try to trade some pieces it does and i'm
not sure about the rook because there is going to
be like a brook e8 maybe bishop f8 idea to trade
everything liquidate and that bishop is doing
a lot more from f8 than it is uh from g7 and i
was just checking if rook d7 was a tactic but it
doesn't look like if there's a roof takes e1 check
good thing to look out for what about bishop c7
speaking of rook takes d7 where's your rook going
yeah wow you almost have to meet
that uh i think you lose an exchange
hang on a sec there's not a good
way to get out of this wait what
suddenly like your movie broke to see it i just
take your bishop because the knight in f3 is
protecting the rook on e1 and if you trade on e7
f8 yeah but bishop takes d8 protects the rook on
e7 so you get to win material there yeah no that's
crazy at this point i think you have to just do
it i don't see a way out he's probably a little
dumbfounded that that works like that that wins
material because then i don't have three defending
the rook on e1 is actually so important it's key
that the rook can even take d7 because of
that so yeah i think i think he goes for that
i don't know what move was better than bishop
f8 there and black certainly has chances in
this game because the bishop pair will thrive
the pawn can go to b4 those pawns are rolling
on the queen side you can blockade that past
pawn which is isolated maybe attack it later
f5 followed by bishop g7 back comes to mind to use
that diagonal and i think levy has chances but i
don't like the clock situation eric is doing
really well and now levy down under 25 seconds
yeah and f5 very interesting move actually it
takes away the e4 square so i i think i think
i completely understand that knight e4 was going
to be really annoying right and niagara's knight d
forcing you take on g4 in comes my knight to c6 or
e6 and that's a problem probably to e6 with tempo
blocks the bishop the g4 pawn will fall right
next and i don't think you could take that thing
the d-pawn captures and goes to e7 that looks like
a big problem maybe rook c8 to prepare b4 and c3
some sort of counter play there keep in mind the
knight is also going to look to jump in to like
d6 as a blockade or even e5 to f3 i love that move
94 the knight f6 check is devastating so he plays
bishop e7 i think you just take on g4 and he does
black down to eight seconds 95 maybe and then the
f3 check and the g4 pawn and knight d3 good move
there what do you do king g2 and then just give up
the pawn but that knight goes to d3 and there's
knight of four check ideas so watch out from g2
they're still forks yep king g2 is very easy to
overlook knight d3 there oh my gosh in 30 seconds
so this is where that extra time plays its part
and he plays rook to d1 to just avoid all the
knight forks that's a good move it is okay so what
now 92 don't buy kg2 that allows bishop v6 knight
for check you want to watch out for knight forks
and he plays g5 and now he's going knight f6 check
yeah now yeah six looks very tempting it has to
be met by just king g7 yeah because kfa drops the
h7 pawn don't want to lose that and knight d5
is coming right there's still h6 ideas though
undermine that knight he goes back and forth he's
not going to take a draw surely oh b3 nice move
bishop six g takes the e7 e6 pawn runs and i said
e7 but it's not there yet but look at that knight
of four hitting the rook and knights through check
takes g5 coming your way now you got knight h3
oh he takes the e6 pawn which also was hanging
but still a good move but knight h3 would have
been crushing their knight takes g5 needed oh my
goodness he barely made a move wait rook takes e6
the rook gets back you take on e6 you're threading
rook 67 with check so bring the rook back to e2
now and you win the game but i think levy had it
there for a split second he did he had it there
there was definitely knight h3 knight takes g5 and
now it's gonna be too little too late as you know
eric is just consolidating bringing everything
back and hey we've seen bishop brook and knight
all on the board in multiple games and it usually
works out for the guy who has the extra rook
that is typically the case and eric rosen takes
the biggest lead he extends his lead to seven
and a half four nav a three point lead and what i
said earlier on is that levy probably has to keep
this within two points he doesn't he has a chance
of coming back even if it's a three-point spread
but you start feeling like it's slipping away from
you so if levy can win this game which might be
our last in this time patrol because we have just
over six minutes left he'll be down by two he has
a chance he's playing this the frankenstein
dracula variation which i loved as a kid
yeah this is a fun opening and especially after
queen h5 um if you're not familiar what to do
with black it's so easy to just lose the game
immediately it really is and this line isn't as
sharp because the queens have been traded their
lines were actually white stays upon down and
tries to go for a checkmate but this is saying
all right we have a neutral looking position
we have seven pawns four minor pieces two rooks
just no queens on the board everything is safe
and sound but knight d5 white is hopping first
into the position and if you play bishop d8 then
white plays c3 takes away the d4 square from your
knight and it's not really much of an advantage
for either player but it's one of those positions
you're like all right we're on neutral territory
let's see who can outplay the other yeah and
both sides are going to do the exact same
thing basically d5 d4 the only difference in the
position is pretty much those bishops on b3 and d8
getting castled is nice and easy for both sides
so again super super equal game here and uh well
as you said get a chance to see both guys with
a fresh position and whoever is able to generate
advantage can say they definitely outplayed
the other i love and hate the move f6 because
it takes away the knight jump from e5 or g5 later
but you can't really play king f7 look where that
bishop on b3 is if that diagonal opens up the king
could get in trouble just because queens are off
the board does not mean that kings are always
going to be safe so if that king does land on
f7 a timely c4 could be big trouble for black
yeah and let's not forget that uh you know levy
is a little bit ahead of development he's castled
you don't need to be castled in games like this
but he is castled which means that you pointed
it out king on f7 it's not always safe to have
you know just that bishop on b3 lined up against
you and he goes bishop e6 oh this this is uh
there's an imbalance here robert so we are going
to see a game somebody bring out their zurich 1953
book because i analyzed a lot of positions just
like this as a child the problem for white is
you have the bishop pair but if we trade the light
square bishops that pawn on d4 actually restricts
the mobility of your dark square bishop i will
plant a knight on c6 bring my rooks to c and e
files and black is the one with the advantage
knights can dance around these isolated pawns
the bishop stares into it and that is not a good
thing for the white side so i've seen many strong
players lose positions like this with the bishop
against the knight and after pawn takes c4 i mean
is there a world of rook takes e6 or wow wait oh
this is hd5 yeah we both said the same time that
is a blunder by eric and levy can just take
that pawn so there's there's d takes c4 after
that for black but he could have played that move
instead of playing g5 this is just him completely
forgetting and overlooking that the arrangement
of pieces here for black is very delicate
and shout out to nemo for the huge raid welcome
everybody sorry we missed it when it happened
and welcome to a very intense matchup between eric
rosen and levy rosman aka gotham chess and he did
just take on c4 theramon rook takes e6 as possible
then bishop takes c4 check the f6 pawn looks like
it's falling as well how many oh oh that's that's
too timid of a move there yeah i liked rook takes
e6 i was thinking about it earlier but now
that the pawns on f6 and hanging i think that's
automatic you take bishop c4 and bishop takes f6
now knight d7 i feel like there's sacrifices here
all the time rook takes e6 again oh yes there it
is king e6 rookie one check the knight on f5 falls
and very importantly the knight on d7 is now
under attack so if that knight we're on b8
this sequence would not work for white but because
the knight is developed it's actually a bad thing
king d6 bishop f4 check i'll save my bishop and
then take your knight if king f7 bishop takes
f5 and then the knight on d7 is lost this should
work out for levy and you can see that uh eval bar
is uh nearly going for the end zone there in
black's position because there's a piece being
lost here and the best that looks like can happen
is maybe two pieces for a rook but there's also
so many pawns that have been taken on the way big
match question for you iman there are two minutes
left in this time control if you're eric you
haven't lost the game completely yet but do you
want one more game in this three minute portion
because you think levy might be the favorite in
bullet or did you say all right let's uh keep this
one going and if the time elapses we'll just head
to bullet and if my lead's two points that's still
a lot i think it depends on whether uh he's the
type of player to even be checking the clock at
this point you know and i think if he is yeah he
might want to play this game out and and say look
let's have this be the last game in this portion
um don't wanna have uh levy mounting a comeback
you know right at the buzzer this is a crushing
position if we can just let the time run out
here and i think that it will based on you
know how long this might take to convert then i
think that's probably what rosen wants take that
two-game lead into the break i would resign so i
disagree with you for the first time in forever
and the reason why is because eric will get the
white pieces and something has been a little bit
shaky for levy in these caro con so i don't want
to give him time to prepare something for bullet
because in that last game his knight went to h6
that was starting to look a bit odd in previous
games his knight a3 lines look good for eric so i
think with the three-minute time patrol he has his
best chance to maintain a larger advantage whereas
he is going to lose this game i don't really see
a way that black survives this yeah he's he's
going to lose this game for sure i i don't think
i could possibly resign a game and then take the
white pieces and consider that an advantage at
least not in this match so i'm just i'm just too
scared to do it you're right i'm on my bad i just
failed you as a co-commentator but the position is
completely lost for black knight forward jack wins
the rook knight of seven there's another fork
94 it just actually wins it and if he resigns
he will get another game i'm looking at the clock
and if he's paying attention he can resign with 15
seconds or 10 seconds left and get one there it
is he resigned he wants one more yep and and he
definitely looked at the clock there or he was uh
cognizant the entire time and will he regret this
because levy could win this game take it to one
point differential but as you pointed out this has
been tough for levy to answer and he might have
thought of that in those dying seconds hey we
need to go back to this does levy have an answer
for this variation and this is where if any player
with the white pieces had an advantage it's been
in this line for eric and you don't want to just
allow things to come down to bullet if you can
get that extra victory then you're feeling good
but i don't think eric's the type players take
risks at this moment he's not going to sacrifice
pieces if it is speculative so i think he made the
right decision and it's still going to be a game
just because he's playing with the white pieces of
course in this match does not mean that he's going
to score a point in fact it's been going the other
way for the most part i just feel like levy's had
a hard time at this point coming up with a way
to counter this opening and you say that but i
want to give him credit here because i think one
of the suggestions i was making the last time i
saw this was maybe a knight e4 uh the knight on
c2 you have to think about what does that knight
not do on c2 what's the difference it's not just a
great move and there's nothing wrong with it it's
a given it take yes you have uh you know the the
d4 square e3 under control but you're not on d2
like usual so knight into e4 f5 supporting and you
sort of get this almost dutch stonewall position
maybe we see him just castle here and say look
take me in the center i've got the strong knight
that you can't get rid of it's kind of funny
because after c4 my thought was knight to c3
and then i just remembered and listen to you the
knight's on c2 so the knight is not on b1 but he
plays 93 he attacks the center that pawn on d5
surprisingly difficult to defend you can play
queen f7 you can't play knight e7 or maybe you can
but i'm looking at c5 as a way to get that bishop
on d6 almost trapped so it's a situation here
where you have to be very careful if you're levy
because when you play d5 and f5 there are weak
dark squares that you have to deal with so i think
the position oh okay go for it so c5 bishop f4 is
available right and so he's not going to lose that
piece of course but it's still it still feels a
little bit shaky but i guess bishop f4 and keep
in mind that light square bishop hey it looks
terrible right now but the maneuver bishop d7
bishop ee bishop h5 it will get there eventually
and that's actually super annoying to deal with
and look at eric justifying his move c4 following
up with queen to b3 there's a lot of pressure
on this d5 pawn and it's actually hanging in the
current position and there could be tactics where
the e4 square is a problem because there could be
a pin on that diagonal so watch out for tactics
here queen a5 play the rook on e1 is defended for
the moment i almost thought wait a second is that
rook under attack no you can take on d5 if you
want but you have to find a follow-up you just
don't take on d5 and hope that it works you need
to find something because black has some tricks up
history with knight to g5 and what a way to
defend that pawn queen a5 is not normally a
resource you lean on to defend your center pawn
especially with all the pressure building up
here the queen lining up towards the king on g8
queen a5 combining defense and attack eyeballing
the rook on e1 as we mentioned i think that's
a great move by levy to try to hold the balance
and watch out for knight g5 right now because that
rook needs a defender and knight g5 thunder just
take on f3 and remove the rook's defense while
shattering the white kingside pawn structure
so levy's thinking here he can take back on d5 but
i feel pretty confident he's looking at knight g5
ideas and that could spell big trouble and there
it is that's a big move it is and you can react to
this in a number of different ways but what
looks unavoidable are the double pawns here
yeah that doesn't look very pleasant either and
well you can react a number of ways or if you're
eric rosen you just don't react at all we don't
even know if he's playing in the game right now
yeah that's true it always uh comes to question
at some point eric's cam could freeze for the
entire broadcast and he would just come back
at the end and i wouldn't notice the difference
for sure and we see him here you know he's
looking at the board trying to figure things out
levy i think he likes his position based on his
posture and look at the clock eric is the one down
under a minute while levy has over a minute and
a half this is turning and maybe i was wrong to
suggest to play another game because levy it feels
like he's hitting his stride at the right moment
yeah and he i think having an answer oh god there
should be four four four it just wins on the spot
and he takes it first but bishop b4 is next
that's over that's over black black wins proper
oh no and it's the biggest reaction
we've seen from eric all day he gulped
and he was just like okay that's a problem there
goes that rook and it went from a potential
two-game lead to a one-game lead so getting that
last game in levy must be like oh you tested me
all right that knight e4 jump didn't see that
one coming yeah and and just having something
ready for that was not expected by rosen because
he's thinking hey that worked out the last time
we played it and i haven't gone back there since
let me do that again it's up to him to show me
that he looked at something and unfortunately
for him the preparation you know it wasn't like
he prepared everything to win but he just had the
ideas prepared and he knew exactly where he wanted
to put his pieces he executed the strategy that
said you got to finish things off here you know
the there's nothing to lose for eric so he's going
to be playing uh until this one is absolutely over
that's right in hindsight they say it's 20 20. i
still think that eric made a good choice i mean
he was looking at his own he had a good looking
position but you have to give full credit to levy
finding this move queen a5 just causing all sorts
of problems the d5 pawn was defended but that's
not what it was about it was the tactics and eric
walked right into a trap now levy brings his queen
to h5 and the pawn h3 is under attack eric has 10
seconds he plays kng2 which is a reasonable choice
i'm looking at that knight trying to get to h4 but
don't move the knight yet then the e pawn starts
rushing up so still not the easiest conversion but
levy should win this without too much difficulty
yeah there's one thing there um you know maybe
it was unnecessary but bishop e6 was potentially
playable because the queen on h5 was watching the
bishop on a5 um and maybe sometimes you can just
sack bring the rook to the middle he decides that
well i think he forgot as well as i was saying
that and that's not gonna that's not gonna cut
it for eric rosen here no that's another piece
down the drain and levy has 40 seconds so he
is way too much time and eric is the type of
player we've said this many times at this point
he plays on until the game is checkmated he does
this all the time it's not a matter of respect
some people think oh it's disrespectful to play
he does against everybody so it's just what he
does and he has every right to continue this
game and the time's up for this time portion so
he might as well and i think when you demonstrate
time and time again that you're able to trick even
the strongest players into a stalemate trap at the
end of a game it's like okay you can you can play
on you know you you are clearly doing that not
out of anything other than your own creative
uh you know canvas to play with and he does it
so many times so um he almost did it in this
match robert and it's just i mean queen takes
e4 was a free rook knight to check you can
take that rook next have fun with it and now
it's an extra rook two minor pieces king is not
safe you have less time everything is going on
for good measures for good measure there goes the
queen and levy he has some bounce because he just
got up he airlifted out of his chair and i mean we
might see him levitate if he is able to continue
this winning streak yeah i know he he just bounced
uh took off to space if his uh sweatshirt was any
indication of where he was playing from uh knight
c5 to finish off a confident game from levy rosman
and we were worried about this happening you know
if you're looking from eric rosen's perspective he
takes that extra game he fully made that decision
robert and now he's probably regretting it do you
think that he's going to be thinking about
a flurry of emotions going into this break
hard to tell by looking at him but he must be
feeling negatively about his chest in the last
few games because levy did outplay him there and
so he's only up by one point he saw the win in
sight three game lead everything's going well and
now it's down to one levee is the high rated ball
player however eric himself is a very strong bill
player i believe his reigns are 26.50 so he should
be right in this come bullets oman i think we're
going to take our final break and when we come
back we will have the bullet portion levy just
at one point you will not want to miss the finale
so
and we couldn't ask for a more exciting match
it is seven and a half points for eric rosen
six and a half points for levy rosman levy
down the scoreboard but on a winning streak
a mom we just took a break so did the players
how do you think they're feeling right now well
if you're rosen you're probably a little dejected
i mean it's hard not to be you could have taken
a two-point lead into this bullet uh segment
completely your decision to get another game
doesn't mean it was the wrong decision at the time
but obviously you look back on that you reflect
and you think man you know what would it could
have shoulda and that's not the right attitude
so hopefully he's not thinking about that too much
but it's very easy to think back on that decision
as you know this match looks like robert it could
come down to a single game in either direction and
it could be that game that he decided to get at
the end of the three-minute portion and we know
he loves to drink his tea hopefully it's heavily
caffeinated because in bullet you need to be alert
at all times you need to be ready for tactics
galore and it has been levy in the last couple
of games who's been striking when the tactics are
available so rosen he's been a bit shaky in the
last two but we can't forget the prior games where
he jumped out to a three-point lead so right now
just the bullet portion left 25 minutes
of it come on i'm super excited man
yeah this is honestly the not only is it really
close going into bullet we've seen that before
but you get the feeling based on this match
it's a win for one side a win for the other
a three-point lead from rosen cut back down
to one by levy neither of these guys is going
out without a fight and i think this is uh
going to be an extremely exciting portion so
you know everybody in the chat strap in b3 on
the board that is bullet opening here we go did
he call hit car during the break because he goes
b3 which is a karu's pet line and e4 upon sack
if you play d takes e4 the f pawn can't capture
the bishop pins upon f3 but it's a pawn sacrifice
and eric spending some time to figure it out no oh
look at this knight c3 knight takes f3 if you take
it just trying to get all the piece out bishop
c4 queen e2 castle queen side and eric saying
you know what i'm just gonna leave that pawn there
for now and keep an eye on this bishop there's a
lot of tricks in this opening like queen b5 check
picking off the bishop on h5 that's a good call
and knight d7 deals with that and says you can
win this pawn back on e4 i'm happy to give it
back to you we kind of have a scandinavian vibe
a scandi where the d-pawn is gone for black the
e pawn's gone for white and wait a sec there
was knight f6 with queen b5 ideas right there
yeah wait a minute knight f6 there's some bishop
takes queen b5 stuff but you have to be careful
that rook on a1 was hanging so don't know if
it was completely winning good call it's easy
to forget because i was focusing your attack but
that rook in the corner was under attack it looks
like eric had things at least barely holding
on there and he was actually that's a good
move when you fianchetto you can push that rook
pawn to try to challenge it a4 locks it up c6 you
can't play b5 just yet your key needs the castle
first whose king is safer because here comes h4
yeah this looks really good for levy h4g4 and
there's already going to be tons of tactics
if you have to play h5 or h6 in this position
complete disaster robert knight takes g6 which is
why he played bishop takes e4 you're thinking hey
giving up that bishop that doesn't make sense it's
because h5 was gonna put that bishop in a coffin
very good call there by eric and if e5 he brings
knight to d5 which is right let me go knight d3
awkward situation with queen e2 bishop f1 blunted
by your own knight and levi can just push all his
pawns g4 threatening g5 the g7 pawns under attack
and g5 still that wins the pawn yeah this this
looks great i mean g7 is hanging why not take that
there's bishop h3 to follow up and hey use that
f file next rook f1 uh this looks fantastic for
levy well done and it looks so strange with the
knight md3 brings it back to e1 not trading pieces
trying to go d4 challenge the 95 and have to drop
back to g6 but there's the f4 square the h4 pawn
there are tactics available for black and he's
evening up on the clock he was down by quite a bit
now it's about uh even yeah and knight d3
can follow up as well covering the f4 square
rook to f1 hitting f7 is gonna be lethal i
feel like going forward h pawn also hanging
yeah levy's final game of three minute was great
this is probably his best game of the entire match
yep there's going to be some counter play with
rook takes h4 and i was going to say levy actually
up on the clock he's more used to the bullet
portion but now it's evened up and it's anyone's
game yeah and then bishop comes to e4 taking on g6
is the priority you could take there and the trade
that works in f8 but then that rook on h4 is kind
of annoying the pawn g5 is weak the bishop on b2
defending d4 but not very active in five seconds
you've got to move exactly rook g1 a bit passive
error gets active and the works on h2 yeah what's
going on b1 king b1 getting out of bishop g5 with
check rook takes g2 queen g2 and already the other
rook comes in i think this is going to be anyone's
game 12 seconds look at the time advantage for
eric rosen and the rooks under attack you're gonna
bring your rook back probably h7 to cover the f7
square good idea rook f7 perhaps queen d i like
that g5 is hanging you can just grab that pawn
but you lose g6 so he's trying to figure it out
he goes queen eight covers that knight f4 oh
this is getting really really good here for
levy i feel like but bishop g5 is a great strength
wait is the knight trapped in g6 rook g7 yeah nice
[ __ ] it's stuck in the corner oh my gosh nobody
puts the knight in the corner except levi e4
oh bishop takes d4 was available there then he
doesn't want it the knight's trapped okay it can
come out but rookie knight d2 oh 92 wins d4 that's
really important and there it goes knight 64 who's
better two seconds a piece oh my gosh rook see
you work up seven you can win b7 you can win c2
there's no mate if both sides are trying to mate
the other knight b5 looks like a good move take
that knight okay see two is hanging so now it's
even material in the rook ending but someone's
going to lose this game though someone has to
good move king ceasing over c6 and he defends
the e6 pawn and now his pawns are safe his king b6
and king c5 can oh you're hanging b7 b7 is hanging
open now the king's coming to b4 rock d6 rookie's
huge is huge he plays it and kicks the fight back
he goes here oh now the b6 and e6 once he's six
and e6 with check okay take him a fourth it's
sure white has lots of time it should be a draw
here rook to e8 the king should chase the bomb
wait for e7 and if rookie five would be a check a
rook b7 though brilliant brilliant defense and one
second oh we touched the book the rook covers
the square look at levy he cannot believe it
oh my gosh it's a typical you're wondering what
the hell was he thinking it's a typical idea when
the pawn is one square from promotion you want to
put that rook anywhere on the board but anywhere
except that square because the rook takes it and
covers the queening square and we're right back
into this opening robert the the emotional
rollercoaster is just beginning all aboard
oh yeah great first half of that game by levy
then great resourceful defending by eric just to
stay in that game and against that knight to the
corner we have this position that eric has loved
the knight a3 variation of the car con levy queen
c7 bishop v6 that's looking good but look at white
aiming on the e file 95 coming and you don't
have that many pieces defending your king
over there on g8 yeah and i wonder i was going
to say is he going to go for knight e7 some sort
of knight g6 to try to plug the position maybe
knight f5 as well uh also using the b file and
maybe getting a knight to e4 the knight on c2 does
not look as effective from this position robert
knight e4 blunts that bishop on d3 that's really
important to get that knight e4 move we saw
levi used that with success in the end of the
three minute portion and now rook to b1 keeping
on that bishop on b7 and 94 still a possibility
here what the problem is for white is you wanna
play bishop g5 and be active but black is just
clogging the lanes knight g6 is your bishop on d3
that's not that good of a piece and if you take on
g6 just h takes closing down diagonals and white's
pieces suddenly don't have the same mobility that
they do in some other positions well you mentioned
hey you can't do this bishop move well he says i'm
doing it anyway and knight d7 instead of knight e4
which i was expecting by levy would have been so
consistent with his play i think that 94 and just
bring the rooks to be it and see it is all levy
needed to do in that position this bishop pair
not terribly convincing and i would consider f
takes here but f even if you have to bishop e7
to d6 that's the idea that eric look at that here
comes that bishop e5 is suddenly very protected
very safe and that bishop on b7 is under attack
so there's no queen takes c3 because then you drop
that bishop down there yeah that's important and
that that b8 square being covered by the bishop
on d6 very underrated there he's not going to be
able to challenge the entire b file maybe for the
rest of the game and i wonder how he's going
to even develop his pieces here like bishop
c6 bishop c5 might have been necessary good move
though a5 bishop a6 just to get that bishop out
the problem is the b file is under white's
control it's the only fully open file in f6
such a dangerous move queen g3 the immediate
response e6 is weak g6 is weak there could be
an ef6 and even a sack on e6 if you're not
careful and eric brings the rook up we're
going to come to f3 otherwise come to e1 that
pawn on e6 is in trouble yeah levy is in big
big trouble here everything's defended i mean
you can take a4 a straight a pawn like we've
seen before but you got to watch out your king is
getting trackmated time is taking you down it's
so hard to play defensive moves under pressure
and look at this just dark square dominance by
white's piece of the e5 bishop f4 queen x4 queen
wow i'm a good move by levy and look at three
oh they couldn't take on e3 that's so hard
to play 96 check wins the queen though
1960 king d7 rookie 7. oh wait that
would have held on for a bit yeah i
mean there's a there's stuff here there's a
rook hanging on e3 it's not completely over
that was wild and we get this line with the early
e4 push by black saying my pawn if i was under
attack by this fiance bishop it's this nimzo
larsen position that's popularized by hikaru
nakamura and typically black should go h5 h4 and
start attacking this nine g3 but you have to watch
out for your opponent e4 and this is actually
a line that i play against this so i've had my
fair share of matches against hikaru i mean i just
can't for the life of me beat him in this in this
line but uh it's a typical way to play what you
do is you have two bishops a wide open central
position whereas white has this sort of snake-like
pawn mass that goes from a2 all the way over to f3
yeah fewer pawn islands are generally a good thing
and having that connected pawns you can go d4
e4 push those pawns forward and that bishop on b2
it may be blocked by the knight from now if you've
ever played g6 that bishop reigns supreme on that
diagonal seem to be very careful yeah and what
we're seeing from eric rosen here is just classic
stuff rooks to the middle of the board open files
this is very easy to play and don't be surprised
to see these bishops even go all the way back to
c8 or f8 because they can exert their pressure
from you know very very far away that's exactly
the strength of the bishop yeah you might have to
rely on that because that bishop can be caught on
h3 just under attack it won't get trapped but
they could be hit with a attack like a rook g3
or something and doubling the rook so you have to
be careful and the bishop may find its way back
to see it as you're saying yeah okay here comes
bishop g6 is it going to be d4 d4 you can always
hammer away at that structure with f5 and he's
going for f4 well you know d4 now with tempo so he
bishop c5 said you didn't play d4 the first time
well now it's probably time to do it with tempo
but that puts the pawns on riskier squares white
has the commanding control the center with the
pawns but you can chip away with f5 or c5 or both
and that center could collapse yeah absolutely the
rooks are poised for that and this is just the
type of thing in bullet it's so hard to keep
everything guarded you're constantly looking is
is e4 protected enough is d4 protected enough
you put too much pressure uh you know defending
one pawn he just attacks the other so you have to
be uh always looking and here we go here's c5 the
first attempt to chip away at that central mass
and c4 it's a thematic sacrifice but maybe i
can just take it because my nf2 is defending
oh but look at that bishop on b6 is that even
a bishop anymore does that qualify as one
wow and he just went for connect four five six in
a row that is looking good eric rosen here he's
got the bishop pair he's gotta activate but he's
got the center here for levy so very double-edged
game oh bishop a7 to go b5 to open that bishop
up here it comes c4 the queen's in line with
the rook the rook wins that battle the bishop on
a7 is alive the next rook can come to c7 this is
look at c3 maybe oh you're in check that's a good
check good check yeah that robert was really on a
roll there there's nothing going to stop him not
even a chat no not even a check i don't care if
it's legal or not i'm doing it but bishop came
to b8 that bishop can come to e5 and then you
can try to push that c pawn yeah bishop e5 here
uh i mean that bishop on f7 it looks like he's
doing nothing but timely f5 or even bishop back to
f7 one second wait one second you gotta go i just
noticed the time and quit if i'm scaring the pawn
a6 queen because i had a great response bishop d4
rook b1 oh my gosh it might be a mate bish should
be sent a good defensive move queen a4 is queen
b5 so he goes back and bishop d6 probably comes
rook b6 go rookie six rookie one rookie queen
oh my gosh queenie five oh rook takes you second
queen wow completely completely crushing levy is
looking to make this a match he can bring the
queen in and he should be able to execute the
mate bring the knight in that's the
last piece that isn't participating
and the key was that queen of four check but none
of us saw that king was in check none of us not
a single one of us not even you amman i know but
you don't even have to check no and now it's over
eric lose on time but he was lost on the board
he was a queen for a rook and a checkmate attack
levy down only two there are 13 and a half plus
minutes right now going back to this carrot con if
you were levy do you continue playing this cairo
because i feel like eric has found a comfort zone
so i feel like eric's found that comfort zone but
it's bullet and changing something up in bullet
can be disastrous if it doesn't work out for you
then you start to lose confidence so i think the
value of him just being able to make quick moves
is going to be fine it's bullet after all and i
think that in general this knight e4 has been a
good counter to this opening once he plays knight
e4 i've usually liked most of his positions and
look at this pawn structure doubled f pawns newer
players hate stacked pawns but what they do a good
job is look at the e4 square that's blacks for the
taking and the king isn't unsafe just because
the g pawn has moved and look at this knight
rerouting over to g6 if i am eric i'm trying
to get open on the queen side as black diverts
pieces to the king side let me play rook to b1
let me play pawn to b5 and use my bishop on h2
which slices across the diagonal taking away the
b8 square and that could be good for white to open
up that side oh look at this why are we seeing
knight a1 we saw knight h8 in a previous game well
it's going to go to b3 it's going to go to c5
and it's going to be a great outpost can never be
kicked by the b-pod because of the pawn on a5 and
he goes king edge one just getting out of the line
with the rook knight e4 played you need to keep
that rook on f1 you do not move that piece into c4
square blacks for the taking the c4 square 16 you
see five square whites for the taking i prefer the
c5 score it actually puts pressure on a pawn where
c4 is staring at air though it's a nice outpost
yeah and and we might see the move g4 at some
point it looks weird but it's sometimes very
thematic and queen e7 it should be six anybody e6
yeah oh it doesn't play it and now the knight can
move out the way because you can capture that
knight and take on b7 and that's an essential
pawn to the defense c4 knight c4 and knight
b5 both look reasonable c4 looks a little bit
closer to the action so to speak the annoying
thing about playing this position the black side
that knight and c5 was never leaving neville and
so you look at the queens that's clogged up here
and bishop h6 is i will give you oh and he goes
f4 he doesn't want that b7 pawn he just wants to
close this position down nobody wants that b7 fun
poor guy valentine's day coming up yeah well it's
it's going stag because gg3 knight goes
back to g6 and maybe now maybe now no no
it's i'm not gonna capture it nobody wants
it it's just a guy looking for a date i mean
oh gosh take it now come on do it a
favor it it's still there surviving
to see another day and if you're not careful for
white this knight on d7 can come to f6 and into e4
and do the same thing the knight on c5 is doing
that's exact that's probably going to happen whoa
d takes c5 is there some rook takes g3 nonsense
no oh my gosh now it's just dominance you if
you trade queen oh trade queens this is really
nice end game for white and you're up two points
you have ten almost eleven minutes in the clock
you can waste a lot of time even if you don't win
this game but black has where are you going for h4
close it down and there's nowhere to make progress
and at some point white can consider the move c4
watch out for that move yeah he's considering it
right now rook do you want anything oops he
had c4 now it's not as good but he can still
play it just to open up the file but g3 pawn's the
problem yeah and and now there's maybe a c4 again
he keeps missing it and then when he
sees it levy's like oh i see it as well
yes but he could still go c4 even if it doesn't
pin the pawn so he's bringing his king around to
play c4 yep here it comes oh my gosh that's really
c7 rook takes d5 but rook takes g3 nice call c4
there it is it's pinned finally and uh levy levy's
in big trouble here takes and rook e5 or although
the g3 pawn hangs so yeah is he going king c3
king d4 whoa i like that move oh king d king d5
who's better here black is better now look at that
king that's a hero and where do you win rookie six
let's bring the rook back rook to e6 g to e6 and
bring the the rooks down this is all of a sudden
good for black you can play d3 and a king d4 and
then rookie two check look at that king it's a
hero went all the way from like g7 to d4 wow and
look at this rookie two check trading off some
rooks king c3 bring that king in oh my goodness
and you can't move you can't take the rook d e's
nothing to do and crooked two meet the king helps
in the checkmate oh my goodness rookie three yeah
this is just completely winning eric gonna waste
some time but it's about to be a one-point match
with nine minutes remaining plenty of time for
levy to continue this comeback that is insane
because we all saw that position and eric was so
focused on trying to make progress that he kind of
forgot that hey if i over push i can actually
lose this game he's going for his stalemate
but he's going to get checkmated instead and as
you mentioned robert a one point game in levy
would you agree he's starting to find his
stride a little bit in this bullet portion
he is and eric had such a good position it was
vision in classical chess he could never lose that
ever it was close he was the one with the
only pawn break with c4 and then somehow he
lost the threat in great move d4 by levy and we
have this nimzo larson attack b3 to start the
compact pawn structure for white the bishop pair
for black and we see levy go back to this but look
at this the early bishop a3 says i can trade the
bishops so the king feels less safe without that
fianchetto there and i don't know if that's good
or bad because you know white's gonna go like
queen f2 d4 maybe rook to e1 and black doesn't
have a bishop pair anymore so now all those
things we were talking about the last time we
saw this don't necessarily apply you can't just
open the position and say hey i'm better i got
a bishop two bishops you can definitely do that
although with the king on b2 knight city
queen e5 could be a big nuisance that pin
is still alive and that's why he plays team b1
that's a nice retreating move the knight now
is free to go but how does white proceed from here
if you play f4 the g4 square becomes vulnerable so
f4 here h5 for block give me that g4 square and
he plays knight e3 first queen e5 i'm bringing
that queen to center taking away f4 from you i i
like queen f2 starting to get on the dark squares
maybe queen h4 f4 uh knight d5 is always in the
position black almost wants to play bishop c8
or bishop d7 and get over to c6 or b7 but maybe
he should have played a5 himself yes this looks
a bit scary but the good news if you take on b6
you undouble your pawn so that is good for black
from a structural point of view but what you need
to do for white is somehow trade a pair of knights
and then try to get on a dark square but it seems
very difficult at this point maybe we can get d4
like somehow play d4 in this knight c4 uh there's
okay there's that move queen e5 f4 comes to mind
f4 it doesn't rook a1 the open a file that makes
sense king goes to b7 knight c4 watch out for that
move that could that big for white to hit the
queen hit the b6 pawn take over some of those
dark stories and look at b right g5 yeah that's
rook g5 is probably good but i like that move b5
just taking away knight to c4 so queen d4 it looks
strange but threatens b4 so he has to go back and
that's a good queen trait that is a very very
good move knight to d1 now if b4 you take the
queen and there's no intermezzo because the queen
can take back on c3 okay so where to go to you
want to use the dark scores for both players right
you want to get this knight maybe to d7 to e5 but
look at this that pawn go to f4 maybe f5 crack
open the king side and that c2 to e4 pawn chain
feels very safe yeah it's so strong but i think
the pawn should have been kept on f3 now maybe
you can try to undermine it i don't know how c4
is but maybe that's too too harsh too right i do
like that move a5 just pushing your pawns where
you have an extra pawn and now rook g8 okay you
defend but fg and then rook to g1 that you take on
f5 you can't take on a five the rook is protected
that actually might be swinging things to black
stuff and there's no rook takes f5 no now you
can just i don't know what you can do now it's
94 though but knight e4 maybe there's knight g4
like can i do something like that right okay
so 94 played i can even take knight takes e4
he plays knight to g4 i do like that move take
that in knight f6 though oh wow because you do
not want to take on g5 that's for sure he plays
f6 not sure about that move yeah i'm not a big fan
of three seconds left for black i didn't even
notice the time if you take on g5 the oh whoa
they're talking about the other thing but oh wait
takes on g6 wait oh they're works hanging the rook
sings you can't take the knight rookie six knight
takes pawn takes and then you have h5 oh roxy's
h5 is winning it's winning for what oh he blew it
he left the rook hanging and he doesn't even react
how do you blunder a rook and just take more of
a nibble out of your sweatshirt and nothing else
who is this guy and levy is about to even the
score he you could sense he breathed it out he's
like this is even but he's still nervous i have to
imagine that eric is nervous too and it's an even
match we're gonna get our knight a3 again and we
have five minutes remaining this is both players
with great chances this is insane i i think by
the end of this match uh eric is going to turn
that crew neck into a v-neck i mean he is just
chomping away there robert bishop f5 we're back
to this opening i actually liked how this was for
levy last time but i don't agree that he should
have traded so many pieces and eric plays rook
b1 and he can play b4a for b5 that's the idea
i was calling for the bishop on f4 is so strong
taking away the b8 square and that's important
because the b file opens up the rook on b1 has
control the rook on a8 or f8 cannot get to b8 so
knight to d7 he's bringing his piece away from
the king side queen d2 bishop h6 is an idea
if you move your kick piece away i can go attack
you but rook g8 of course is going to be e8
yeah and this is going to be the classic
setup don't underestimate that knight on d3
kind of a hero guards the b2 pawn so the rook and
queen both do not have to worry about it and it's
watching both the c5 and the e5 squares knight
g3 you can already see where that knight might
be heading maybe the h5 to support queen over
to h6 but usually in these positions robert
black actually uses the open file to attack white
more than the other way around yeah and i think
that with this bishop trade here if you take and
play rook g6 that looks good for black i might put
my bishop back because your pieces are fighting
for the g file your bishop on g7 wants to get out
of there so bishop f4 for example says yeah that's
staying close because knight e5 but now i see yeah
there's a pin on the f2 pawn so there could be a
rook takes g3 that you have to look out for yeah
and we both tuned into that immediately the queen
on b6 looking at the king on g1 you might say well
there's so many things in the way but keep in mind
that rook on g8 looking at taking that mga 3 for
free but i don't think it's quite working it's
just an idea to keep in mind for calculations and
he goes knight d7 so he retreats and now bishop g7
knight h5 white can play for that mission we were
talking about but the e5 pawn is that a strength
helping white secure the f6 square or is it a
weakness because it's already under attack it's so
tough to tell rook g6 uh looks reasonable knight
to f4 of course can be played and that rook might
just slide back to g7 big question is can white
play queen to d4 offering a queen trade and then
try to take over the c file and that's something
that's easy to miss because you're so focused
on the king side but if the c file opens up and
white can get both rooks over there that could
be problematic for black and i like king and shoe
just maybe saying it looks nice like going all the
way like switching sides so quickly queen d queen
h4 in two moves the queen went from b6 to h4 and
suddenly there's a king side attack and there's
queen d4 watch out for knight h5 knight f6 but
the g2 pawn was hanging so he goes g3 good move 10
seconds per side 94 hits the f2 pawn maybe a sack
on g3 if you're not careful so he plays rook to e2
and there's no sacrifice on g3 it will not work so
he's not going to go for now whatever knight three
do not allow that fork six seconds my
goodness okay he brings the queen back
very very very crucial to stop that knight goes
back to e4 h4 played quickly but i think this
is going in levy's direction there are so many
sacrifices on each four to worry about queen d8
oh my god it's hanging there's going to be my gosh
and if you move your knight there's a knight takes
g3 and the queen d4 is hanging one second you
barely got to move because brook takes h f4 and
it's mate and four seconds for levy and he takes
it quick the queens trade the queen oh the rook's
hanging that's huge that's you yeah if i'm eric
you gotta resign you gotta well i guess you only
have time for one more regardless but levy is
about to take the lead in this match and it's up
to eric rosen to i think he's gonna resign here or
not sure if he knows the situation but he's gonna
get one more game anyway so it doesn't matter
it all comes down to that game if he doesn't win
and the game is over by timeout if he does not
win this game it is all over robert and one of
the most insane comebacks that we've ever seen is
about to be upon us and did you see levy hold his
heart i i don't know if he could take much more of
this i don't know if i can take much more of this
but we get this funky variation with the queen on
e2 blocking the bishop but levi he's been having
success with his king darting over the queen side
but this is different it's not the position we've
seen before whoa what is that g4 h5 in a game
where i only need to draw i'm not sure i'm going
for this wow and h6 played very quickly by rosen
he doesn't want to calculate anything he says look
this saves my bishop that's all i need
to know and look at the swiss cheese and
the dark squares on the king side over here and
the king can go to queen side for what you just
castle right now but then watch out for d4 and e5
and c5 and i don't like this position for white
yeah all of a sudden that bishop on h7 wide awake
and looking at that c2 pawn you're not going to
take it right now but it's about the pressure
black's going to play c5 knight c6 maybe knight
before knight d4 and all of a sudden the knight
and bishop work together on the c2 pawn and
a5 he says look if you were ever thinking about
casting that way don't forget i've got an attack
coming oh gosh and now the b4 square is blacks
for the taking bishop takes c2 everybody was
not possible because this d3 movement to trap the
bishop uh so oh actually the b3 pawn was hanging
so after a4 that could have been a blunder and
maybe he could have taken c2 i wasn't looking but
here no matter what terrible this is really bad
for white in a you don't need to win this game you
just need to draw c3 that b3 square the d3 pawn
maybe there's a knight c5 hitting both at once
and it seems like white's position on
the verge of collapse look at the time
he's gonna flag this game in the opening
bishop c3 takes takes there's like queen b4
queen d4 so many winning winning moves here oh
my gosh queen c5 queen d4 everything looks good
he goes bishop e7 no he missed something he missed
something there for sure richard one is available
oh gosh but roxy one that's also ugly he goes
bishop no we need to use his knight takes yeah
i forgot about that piece i was going for the fork
d4 though just push d4 yeah or bishop c5 bishop's
e5 g5 is also great for sure at 26 and 25 to 10 he
plays c5 i don't like that movie either knight f3
all of a sudden white's getting developed you
need a rook h2 he's not developing anything
and eric's just trying to play c4 himself because
that bishop on h7 might be the hero at the end
how do you stop c4 c4 is is going to hurt and
you've you need to move like once a piece he
loses the beast and eric's going to win and
tie the match oh my gosh he's 25 we're still
in this game we're still in this game oh are we
yeah we are because anything can happen when you
have votes from we made it with a point one he
made up one point five he's barely getting off
take it black is completely winning but we'll see
how the nerves are here because i'm nervous bro
six the queen on eight six five shot oh my gosh
he takes it with a rook that's a good move he's
still winning two pieces for the rook put a knight
on e3 watch out for knight e takes into a 93 check
yeah that's e62 oh my goodness it's saying
there's also queen g6 and you can just you
can check this knight g493 do something thank
you for check here comes oh my gosh if there's
not a check me in a few moves i don't know how my
time is a time match oh my goodness we have a tie
and somebody's alarm went off you know
what that means it's not time to wake up
it's time for this time break time yep that was
that was my tie break alarm there robert and let's
read the tie breaks so it is a tie right now it
is 10 and 10 now we get four additional bullet
games it's a mini match if you score two and a
half points you win if it's tied two to two we go
to armageddon where white gets five minutes black
gets three minutes but with the draw odds and what
we see early in the match black was winning all
the games hey i want to pick black but i get three
minutes we've seen the time trouble this match
hey i'm not going two minutes down from move one
so amman the player with the higher blitz rating
choose the color that means levy will choose the
color if we get to armageddon i don't know if
we'll get that far but what would you choose
well robert let me start off by saying i
didn't even know we had tie break rules
we hardly ever get to use them but it is so
exciting to be in a tie break format what
color would i choose honestly the black pieces
have been stellar for both sides today they
cannot be underestimated and i think it's less
about what color you would choose and more about
how comfortable and how confident these players
are going to be containing their nerves because
this has been one of the most exciting matches
i think we've ever hosted and they get no break
they're going right back into things and that i
mean who's that better for eric won the last game
but levy seemed to be the better of the two that
far in the bullet he came back from one point down
tied the match he was up by a point until that
last game there so he was storming back eric
says hey not so fast let's go to tie break who has
the edge psychologically as we go into tie breaks
well eric rosen does because he's stone cold
the entire time he's doing that how how did
he not break a sweat crack a smile no show of
emotion um but in all seriousness no this is a
literal toss-up robert uh i i cannot possibly call
this both players playing so clutch under pressure
and we saw that thumbs up clearly the team
behind the scenes doing all the work informing
the players exactly what's going on of course
they could read the rules beforehand they likely
have but just reminding them because tie breaks
don't happen very often it is four game mini match
two and a half points wins and well we've seen
anything can happen in bullet eric wins that final
game levy probably feeling a bit shaken because
he just need to draw he started playing wildly
and the nerves are getting to both of them even
if eric has not moved a muscle except to bite
his sweatshirt a little bit yeah this is going
to be a series of very intense matches because
it could so easily go to armageddon it's been that
connect the entire time i think that levy has done
a bit better in the bullet but when it mattered
when he needed a win eric rosa just stepped up
to the plate and played the best game of the
match and here we go we're going to get this
knight a3 line i am sure and bishop b3 c3 here
comes knight a3 to c2 we've liked these positions
for the most part for eric but this bishop f1 51
excuse me that's been going pretty well for levy
yeah and i don't see why he wouldn't go back to
it uh there's also his e6 line that he's been
playing with knight e4 but g6 bishop f5 and look
did he check that in the last like five seconds
i'm not sure if he did but he said no bishop
f5 for you you could play e5 and get the iqp
and levy says not for me i'm playing e6 and
maybe b5 but we've liked those positions
for white that's for sure yeah maybe knight e4
with f5 yeah exactly and this is another setup
it's not easy to play the move f3 to kick that
knight out when the move h3 is on the board the
dark squares get too weak and this feels like
it's a move behind for black's amount because
we saw f5 was already there in 97 the queen
a5 position so somehow black seems to be down
on g7 instead of d6 it takes an extra move to
fianchetto and that's good because stairs is a d4
pawn but now how does black get out of this a3 to
kick the knight that's why it goes knight back to
f6 but we like that knight in the center and now
maybe c5 b4 push those queen side pawns that has
some risk for the d4 pawn though yeah but it's so
it's so easy and bullet to do something like that
you know what your next bunch of moves are going
to be and it just helps you play quickly and get
up on the clock as you see that's already
the case and a5 is a great move stopping b4
before it can happen knight g4 let's turn off the
knights if you take me i take towards the center
my pawn and d4 is protect i'll bring my bishop to
e3 so i like this decision but black and try for
b6 trying to break open that position yeah knight
takes g4 or you can just leave it and play d6
he says no e5 and i like that response
i don't know what the evaluation is but
he wants to get that bishop out from ca i both
like it and dislike it the bishop wants c8s out
but so is that bishop on c1 if you took an e5 the
bishop would go to h6 that's why he took on c5 but
he could bishop e3 bishop d4 planting that bishop
on d4 and powerful look at levy say no not for you
here comes d4 but that pawn on d4 could be
weak queen d6 or queen v6 hitting the b2 pawn
keep in mind queen d2 guarding the pawn g4
just hangs as a result and black's going to
bring the rooks to c8 d8 and i feel like i like
this position for levy and f3 says i'm going to
protect but do not move that bishop from d3 you
move that bishop d3 check happens and that could
be a problem so he goes queen c2 why is control of
the open file black has this passport on d4 i feel
like white should be a little bit better and queen
e6 is an idea you have to be careful i don't like
queen v6 queen d6 annoying so i like bishop f8 to
prevent queen d6 so maybe queen b5 queen a7 we've
seen queen e7 win some games but that could lose
you the game as your queen's really far away he
just takes that's the modest queen c4 and look at
that he dragged the bishop out so he could attack
the pawn queen seven a good response there's no
quincy one don't blind your queen there yeah no if
either queen penetrates the position specifically
black's queen uh it might be all over but look at
those bishops that either defending two seconds
once oh my gosh he barely got that move off in
time and we should be seven almost shot the
queen there's queen eight to get away from it
it's a queen city oh boy that's a that's a draw
that's true if he wants it there might be more
i don't know where more is but maybe there is more
kingdom does that secure the draw at this point
he is thinking about bishop f1 but he should
not play that movie he did it oh my goodness
oh my gosh and he does it wait check he missed
it without king f2 king of two bring your kingdom
bishop c5 hey wait is there d2 big a3 oh d2 d2 is
winning wow and that decision by eric he shook his
head the first real reaction we've seen from him
he was like i can't believe that just happened i
played bishop f1 was so unnecessary he didn't need
to do that you just be okay with the draw and go
to the next game sometimes you play for a win you
play for a loss and that's what's happening here
levy keeps his composure with seconds maybe
even just barely half a second on his clock
in certain moments and he is winning this game
it takes a one game lead in this mini match
yeah i mean we're still in this game but this is
going to be a win for levy yeah he has an extra
piece and now he can take him play bishop g7 trade
off the bishops and then promote the pawn yeah i
think bishop f8 bishop g7 is the easiest i mean
look at rosen he's going for stalemate he's going
for stealing close to it oh look at that taking
the bishop and you can just go bishop c6 and then
take the queen and then promote no stalemates
for you i mean he's so close every time though
and i feel like that takes the wind out of eric's
sales because he won that final game to send this
to the tie breaks and he's the one who chose
to play on and levy was like waiting for it
he says you're going to have three seconds i am
going to win this game and now levy rosman up
one point three games remaining in this mini match
yeah and we see already a different move knight f3
instead of the f3 we've been seeing and one thing
we've said and we've seen from eric rosen is he is
clutch robert you cannot deny that when he needed
to win he won the game he needs to win right now
to get back in this he certainly does and look
at this setup if white plays d4 to challenge
the center black plays e4 takes up space and
especially with that bishop with d6 so i like
the c4 move challenging the center in a different
way and that pawn d5 is not protected right now
and it could be some problems in the light squares
yeah and knight takes d5 we've seen positions like
this before in this match with the f6 but those
light squares always a force to be reckoned with
this bishop on g4 there might be a d4 move a5
looks super strong and a6 soften up all the light
squares over there and watch out your knight on
c6 not well defended so bishop back to e6 okay a6
b6 the problem with a6 is that pawn later in the
game can become a target but right now it's such
a problem for black the rook can't move from a
the a7 pawn needs defense e4 once again you do
not want to open the position if you're playing
uh with the black pieces here something like f5
we've seen a structure exactly like this earlier
on maybe oh i was going to say knight f6 made more
sense than knight c8 yeah knight c8 that's not a
fun move to play and i think the bishop can go to
b4 as well maybe not now because the rook's in c1
but this is not the way you want to go for eric
and he puts his pieces look at that default so
clogged and if you can get f4 that would be good
but now cc77 yes at least in exchange there yeah
wha what do you do about this i think you buy c
takes d he thinks for the knight but i was taking
the c pawn up in 97 just i would lose my rook but
not the pawn knight f6 maybe had to be played
there or something like that oh this is rough this
is rough knight takes a8 bishop takes d6 and levy
once again is just cementing this this uh position
although he doesn't win the more material he
does simplify that's a great move bishop c4
trade off some stuff there will not be an attack
for black in fact white is controlling the c
file so here comes the queen down to c8 c7
and the a7 pawn that's probably going to be
lost soon yeah maybe knight f8 simply forced here
rook c6 berks c7 looks great and you mentioned
there's going to be no attack for black he can try
desperately with f4 but h5 none of these moves are
actually threatening anything no and here comes
queen c4 if you wanted to try 87 yeah that's nice
and rook c1 rook c7 that pawn is going to be taken
and i i think this is another win for levy look he
had 38 seconds robert yeah something just you know
snapped in eric and he was playing really well
he won that final game but this one was never his
once levi struck with c4 and then the knights got
awkward in a4a5 really nice play by levy knight
c7 rook takes a7 king c6 he's trying to trap that
rook but keep in mind there's always rook b7
check yeah and he takes g7 the a pawn goes and
while you're up pawns on both sides of the board
initially exchange and now all levy needs is a
draw one draw wins in the match and eric going
back to his favorite weapon here with knight
a3 yep this is a draw wins the match there's four
games it's a four game mini match and it's already
two nothing for levy rosman you can see the two
point advantage reflected in the score he's back
to this bishop f5 system and eric rosen's saying
look that whole knight e3 thing forget that let's
go back to the basics and what has worked in the
past yeah he goes 93 now so he takes away the f5
square and the knight on f6 needs to keep an eye
on the d5 pawn so you have to watch out for that
because 28 protecting getting his queen back and
i still like these positions for white it's just
my preference levy has done nothing wrong it's
solid it just feels much more easy to play from
the white side yeah and i think he somehow got the
best version almost all match like he's got the
bishop out in front of the knight on e3 and knight
e4 can be instantly kicked away by by simply f3
and knight a5 trying to get to the c4 square
i was thinking that white would play knight
c1 knight b3 knight c5 but now the 985 covers
the b3 series bishop g5 watch out for knight g4
that's going to be a very frustrating pin and if
you play h6 the bishop just goes back to h4 so
queen of c7 that's good getting out of the pin and
we get a little repetition a little tickle levi is
going to take the repetition and i think we know
why he wins the match with a draw keep that in
mind uh going forward in this and that's a sneaky
move because if you ever play h6 you could have a
problem with that square so 94 hitting the bishop
he takes that's a big choice i was just going
forward he wants the dark squares but i think
he could have had them without trading yeah but
he came with bishop f4 and then knight to e5 so
that way he doesn't drop a pawn to get the knight
to e5 right now i don't think 96 check is good no
knight h6 king h8 and you your knight is actually
just trapped on h6 you might wish that it was back
there bishop f4 great move and if you can bring
that knight to e5 you're saying that bishop on c8
even though it can get the b7 maybe to d5 perhaps
there's nowhere for it to attack and you would
like to trade off some of these miners yep knight
to e5 we haven't even seen development completed
by levi is he gonna go knights before he does
take that off take and bishop h6 and play knight
against light squad bishop that's what i would
be doing i know it's not a classical game but it
feels like black doesn't have any active play and
white's just jumping in here yeah but keep in mind
that bishop if it gets to d5 clogs the position
all of a sudden it could be black going f4 and
where is white's play that's true i was thinking
that i would get my knight to f4 but you're right
if you can kick my pieces out of there and then
press four that could be a problem so b3 now play
b3 open up that other flank b3 but b3 c takes b3
you can't stick with the rook there's bishop a4 so
you have to be careful a little bit bishop c6 to
d5 now and he's not getting b3 i think bishop
d5 if he doesn't play b3 there's no play left
yeah maybe h4 to try to crack the king side
as well but here's g5 oh oh here comes f4
wow and the bishop does cement itself and if
you take on c4 the bishop lands there can you
even go to defense look at the clock as well
there's eight seconds he's in a tough position
clock ticking down but we've seen him be clutch
before this is still anyone's game yeah and watch
out for the king side attack if you go f4 you
drop e4 the g5 pawns in attack it goes queen g6
that's a good move but you have trouble playing f4
for black so he plays h4 but now f4 the pawn still
could be hanging i like to move rook before
yes whoa it takes a night that's shocking
very shocking well there's gonna be g4 to follow
but uh eric rosen has got to be happy with his
chances here yes because now all things
are opening up and rookie three very good
f4 oh no or maybe not the three move f3 and go
for checkmate oh my gosh this might be so quickly
rookie three play but g takes h3 and the queen
comes down to g2 and that looks like game h2
okay but you can't stop h2 there goes the pawn
get a queen yeah a draw oh he's fist pumping
he's fist bumping he's still got the game to
complete but the queening and he's got it he's
up a rook and there has to be a checkmate in
the next few moves so levy rosman against all
odds he was down three points at some moment here
he goes checkmate next move and that is the match
and look at levy he is elated there is a fist
bump he's gone it's probably jumping around his
room i feel sorry for whatever objects he has
around him they're probably breaking right now
holy smokes the emotions finally pour out
because they've been bottled in the entire match
rosen and rosman just gave us probably one of the
best treats ever for in terms of entertainment
robert you know bringing you this prime time show
i'm not a gm maybe any speed chess championship
match i feel like this has been the most exciting
it really was and it kind of got to be a little
bit of a frozen rosin in these time scrambles
he was using a lot of time levy was just locking
things up and he couldn't find the right moves
even when he had his chances of real credit to
both of these players we got to take our final
break because we need to return with them we can
hear their thoughts and we're gonna have to know
what was going on with the black pieces winning
the first nine games of the match so stay tuned
everybody we'll be back with levy and eric very
shortly
and we are back i know the chat is going wild
right now uh from that completely insane match
in terms of entertainment robert and i are on
the edge of our seats we have the players levy
and eric joining us here and i i just go right
to you levy the the emotions we saw them come
pouring out of you on camera right at the end
there some fist bumps we were worried about you
know the projectiles and some of the objects in
your room but can you just describe how you're
feeling after an insane match victory uh i mean
yeah what what to say um first of all uh eric
that was a lot of fun uh we should do that again
just maybe not so soon uh in a few days right
i i mean i i at some point i gave up preparing
for eric you just can't do it uh and so as the
match was kind of spiraling out of control i
actually when i went three down i left and i
and i went to talk to my girlfriend and i was
like mentally i was preparing what i was gonna
say when i when it was over and i lost because
i was just okay i mean and then i don't know
it just moved pieces to squares and
uh yeah i mean at the end it's just
raw emotion what else to say no absolutely it was
a really heated match it was going back and forth
and eric let me ask you something the match
started with nine wins for the players with the
black pieces so what was going on did that kind
of feel weird to you or was that just par for
the course of what was going to be a wild match
yeah it was a little bit strange um i was i wasn't
really keeping track but i knew that it seemed
like black for some reason had the upper hand
and that may have been because that we both
prepared very well for black and not so well for
white oh not not at all i mean like most of the
games were coming down to like much later moments
and these crazy time scrambles so it may have been
psychological may have been coincidental but um
uh yeah levy levy played well especially to come
back from i think he was at a three-game deficit
yeah so twice right it was rough but uh i'm really
i was really hoping you wouldn't keep playing e4
um but then you kept playing e4 yeah i wanted
to keep punishing your kero khan but maybe in
hindsight maybe i should have switched to london
i was like waiting at some point at some point i
pre-moved c6 and i got very scared because i was
like um yeah i don't know about eric but like i i
you look at some lines and then you're like okay
i'll you'll just figure it out um i was pretty
unhappy with with some of the five plus one
i still can't figure out how to play the time
control correctly of course like we barely play it
so uh i felt those positions were a lot of fun but
for the first i mean for the almost the entire
five plus one basically the entire three plus
one it just felt like eric was more clutch held
his nerves better um outplayed me like i mean
there was moments i was staring at the board
and he played a move and i'd be like oh yeah
like not even that it's good that it's legal
that he'd play a move and then he was just
once it was three down i just kind of was
like okay whatever we'll see what happens
and then i had nothing in the next game and yeah
i don't know just momentum swings i just i wore a
fitbit to track my heart rate i was telling
eric and uh i averaged 130 beats per minute
for like the last hour so probably pretty
unhealthy for me to keep playing these matches
yeah i was saying the same thing it
would be a good thing that robert and i
did not have heart monitors on the screen because
ours were definitely up there as well um erica go
to you again because it looked like you made
a decision i was wondering if it was conscious
or not at the end of the three minute portion
it looked like you resigned to take another game
um and you know that game obviously ended up
going too levy kind of shrunk that lead you
know is that an intentional decision and is it
something you sort of look back on in this match
yeah um it was a conscious decision i was
aware that there was like i think 15 seconds
left of the 3-1 portion and i was debating
whether to resign just yet another game um
and i mean i i was liking my prep
preparation with white so i think
if i was in the same situation again i probably
would have made the same decision but of course
the game uh that was probably one of my worst
losses is white because i just blundered this uh
this bishop b4 move levy played really tricky
that final game so he got that uh that momentum
shift high praise honestly i like i said i was
just the last few games was just making moves
and then you played queen c3 and i was like oh
uh and you know playing eric is like it's kind
of a nightmare because when you play most title
players you get upper rook like okay next game but
with eric it's a constant lingering fear that he
will completely embarrass you and he almost did he
i almost almost he almost got a stalemate trap
like in the first section or something and i'm
constantly sitting here with this fear like i'll
end up on a highlight somewhere you know and uh
it's no it's the stress is never over until he the
game literally pops up that i it's over and i won
the stress is insane well levi let me ask you
something because you mentioned momentum shifts
and stress when eric won that final bullet game
to tie the match and send the tie breaks that's
a momentum shift eric's way how did you calm
yourself because you didn't even get time to rest
before going into more bullet what were you saying
to yourself what were you thinking you know what
was that experience like to be honest i would love
to give you some big inspirational speech but um
it ended um i knew i mean that whole that game
i must have hit 150 throughout the game i just
like kept trying to calm down and kept playing
garbage moves it was really a fun process and i
was like you know we'll just play and at that
point i really expected d4 because i'm like
okay it's brand new four games and he plays e4
and then we get another like what i don't even
remember what what iteration of the move order it
was and like i said i was just gonna put pieces
on squares and try to play the best move and try
not to get low on time and uh i got my chance and
then in the next game i don't even remember what
opening i played in the second game of the bullet
but um oh i played this like b3 bishop b2 e3 and
i made that decision i made consciously i was
like the next time he does that i'm going to play
that but other than that just stay focused and uh
hope for the best that's basically it right i mean
this this entire match basically felt like uh it
came down to a match of nerves especially with all
the time scrambles and you yourself eric pretty
much on camera i think everyone would echo these
thoughts that you look like nothing phases you you
know you'll you'll hang the biggest blunder of
the match and you'll look the same as when you
have that clutch victory to send the entire match
into armageddon can you give some insight are you
actually nervous under there at all or are you
just unphased in these scrambles well i'm i'm
actually curious uh maybe next time i do one of
these matches i should wear a heart rate monitor
because i get nervous but um i mean one of the
ways to calm nerves is just to not show anything
and just kind of try and find that sort of zen
mode so um of course like i'll feel the adrenaline
but um i don't think there's too much reason for
me to get emotional or like if i have a tough loss
or blunder something i'm not gonna like throw
anything or break anything so it's one of those
things that uh i've lost lost enough games over my
uh my career to kind of cope and just move on with
uh just take it one move at a time yeah that makes
sense and you mean levy in one of those games
it's hard to call it any moment a moment of the
match but there was that rook takes f7 so the
queen takes up seven and you have queen b1 and saw
that checkmate on the back rank like moments like
that like how do you play in next game because
whether you win or lose that there's so much
emotional adrenaline rushing through you like
how do you just gear yourself up to keep going
um well you you have to actually was that the
wasn't there was there a break after no no we
there was another game there was another game
one more after that yeah yeah um i mean i think
it's different what time format you do it and
i think in five plus one it it's like it takes
forever for the game to kind of get going uh
that was actually a game i was talking about
i was winning and then eric like defended really
well i mean and i got low on time and in my head
i'm thinking highlight highlight reel highlight
reel i'm losing losing losing and then as i play
rook f7 i'm like if he takes with the rook i
have queen b1 with like 1.5 seconds on the clock
you know and he takes i barely got the move there
first of all like you know mouse moving like this
and then it was just mate um but i did the same
thing against canty i uh i had a good win and
then the next game i completely self-destructed
um yeah i mean when i was basically losing games
during the breaks i would like walk outside
i would do the daniel cormier i would walk
like one way to down my apartment and then one
way back and just like be like let's go like come
on like focus and then i would like sit back
and lose more games it was a really cathartic
experience i must say um now i won't sleep till
three in the morning i don't know about eric but
ah yes and eric i do have another question
for you and one of those games in the bullet
i think it was the first tiebreak game if i'm not
mistaken you'd made this decision to bring your
bishop back to f1 instead of repeating moves with
king g1 to h2 and i hate to bring up bad memories
but what was your thought process like there
because levi did not have much time but it felt
like you could go for the repetition and go to
the next game so how did you make that decision
to sort of play for a win ah i i was just about to
suppress the memory and then you you brought it up
eric you know we're friends i'm sorry i'm so sorry
i forgive you um yeah it was kind of a practical
decision i um i mean levy had two seconds
left and i saw that he shouldn't be queening
but then he had a promotion tactic to win a piece
and then i was just lost so of course that was uh
that was unfortunate because i could have
just taken a draw and then moved on but um
it was it was kind of a calculated risk
in the moment and that didn't pay off
yeah i think that's the that's the
best summary an honest answer i mean
those are just game time decisions comes down to
just seconds uh i think it's fair to say this was
literally one of the most exciting scc matches
and i am not a gm and maybe in just sec overall
that most people can remember that i can certainly
remember commentating it went all the way to a tie
break it nearly went to armageddon so i think
that just speaks how to how closely matched the
entire thing was um go over to you levy and you
know congrats because you you did come out uh on
top with the roller coaster of emotions and you're
probably not thinking about it but you are moving
on in the competition and greg jihadi is waiting
for you on the other side of the bracket um any
thoughts towards that match or you know just kind
of trying to get the heart rate down i think i
think it's down no it's still above 1.05 so uh my
resting heart rate is like 59 so it's going to be
a while um uh no i mean greg is really strong uh
he actually it's funny he messaged me before the
tournament began and he was like you want to talk
some trash like on social media he's very like
contrary to what he like puts out on twitter i'm
like man i'm not even sure i'll even make to make
it to play this man it wasn't a matter of him he
would he would make he's fine um i was like we'll
see you know because the first time we did this i
was knocked out in the quarterfinal i'm like we'll
see when we get there so i don't know man um this
time i tried to drink some wine in the beginning
of the match to like cool off that didn't work
i almost fell asleep who knows next time i don't
yeah well it's late for both of you uh we
appreciate you taking the time and everyone
was delighted and treated to a great match
i mean there's so many people still here
it was the numbers were through the roof
and everybody was rooting for both so we
really appreciate you coming on playing a great
match and obviously for all the work you do for
chess in general it's an absolute joy to see you
both thrive and the numbers speak for themselves
so it's a lot of fun guys well i i hope the
commentary was fun um shout out to you know
everybody in the chat i saw the energy was
electric it's a good it's a it's a it's a
healthy rivalry you know i should say that eric is
uh one of the only probably the person i've known
the longest in all of this online over-the-board
stuff um he's one of the only people who
at the beginning of last year i even saw in person
because he stayed at my place or was that january
that was yeah that was january last year yeah
i mean it's like crazy how much has changed so
ah that was good it was good to play this match
if i was gonna lose to anybody i was gonna be
happy to lose to eric same with you levy but um
we're gonna you know go back to the drawing board
keep uh keep making content streaming and uh shout
out to you guys for hosting and shout out to the
chat for being electric well we appreciate it good
word that's a good word for the chat electric was
exactly the energy and uh another congrats to
you levy but especially eric for making this uh
literally one of the most uh memorable matches for
for everyone here so congrats to both and thanks
again for taking the time to join us all right
thanks guys have a good night you too and there
you see it the bracket is set the final four
it is greg shahadi levy rosman roberto molina
lars oscar hogg amon we just had a wonderful match
and if we look forward we see levy taking on greg
you asked him he said well there was potential for
trash talk he didn't give a definitive answer on
what his thoughts were what are your thoughts on
both that match and the roberto versus lars match
uh it's it's actually pretty incredible to uh
remind ourselves robert that that wasn't the final
you know what i mean that felt like a finals
match so that just speaks volumes about how
closely matched those two players are levy moving
on he's taking on greg greg's the number one seed
we all know that he uh comes into this you know he
must be the the favorite on paper but we've seen
so many ups and downs from levy it could be you
know his terrible time management might cost him
the entire five-minute segment or his resilience
in the bullet might win him the whole match so i
think it's a very interesting matchup but i will
say that levy probably knows himself he needs to
find a way he mentioned it in our interview
here needs to find a way to play the five-minute
segment properly because he just doesn't have
any practice in that exact format format five
minutes plus one second increment and greg jihadi
has so much experience he's obviously older than
levy he's been playing blitz as a favorite of
his for a long long time you can go on youtube
and find really old clips of him doing that he is
higher rated he's the number one seed so far it's
been rock chuck jayhawk one through four making it
to the semi-finals and levy has his work cut out
for him but what is showing we don't even want to
think ahead at this point we'll just focus on the
match that was because we have two fantastic
streamers who can also play some mean chess
that was awesome it was wholesome to hear their
thoughts their friends when they're not competing
against one another and eric despite the loss he
proved that he was every bit the match for levy
rosman and we could not have asked for a better
show no there's no other way to put it um the the
chat i think i don't know what the the max viewers
was but it was upwards of 22 to 25 000 uh watching
so so many fans of both of these players and just
chess fans who maybe haven't uh seen these guys
hey these guys are active streaming on twitch all
the time you know so if you you liked uh what you
saw today you can get a another taste of that
on on their channels respectively so just a an
incredible incredible day i had a feeling this
was going to be one of the most hyped matchups
uh prime time slot uh we got our producers staying
up until 7 00 a.m plus uh uh their robert just to
make this show happen so i'm glad i'm glad we did
because it's been a pleasure i don't know what my
heart rate is i don't know how i'm going to sleep
tonight but that was a great match and we want to
thank everybody who's been tuning in throughout
this whole way between two very popular chess
personalities gotham chess i am rosen there
could be only one winner it was levy but on
behalf of myself and amman gonna say goodbye say
goodnight and we'll see you soon for more chess